fab dans ce championnat du monde à berne
rien n'est joué il n'y a que trois
points d'avancé à quatre parties de la
fin donc autant de dire que j'eusse
peines et aux têtes même n'est pas
favori là quand il est dos au mur et
n'est jamais aussi dangereux donc
franchement je m'attendais victoire
éclatante aujourd'hui tu vas d'ailleurs
il fait appel à un technicien pour venir
à lui joué son premier coup on de son
équipe
extraordinaire à mon avis à fabien la
partie qu'on va qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui parce que les pneus étaient
plus trop sûr de ce qui est joué donc il
est bien besoin du gars pour lui montrer
je joue bien eu quatre et on va refaire
une anti marchal retrace évoque ce que
c'était à prévisions ça me ferait
plaisir sa
femme avait prévu l'anti marshall
aujourd'hui il la colle avant le avant
l'arrivée en fait il a dit comme dépôt
doit faire semblant de jouer mais que ça
doit le saouler il peut refaire une anti
marshall et à pas de chance j'ai réussi
il est vraiment trop fort vraiment j'ai
eu un micro avantage mais rien à faire
on s'attend on s'attend à ça à une
italienne et cher a tancé 4 parce qu'on
est on en est sûr et on en est sûr
j'ai cinq ans et demande un peu
théorique et les cinq ça peut être
marrant n'empêche pas de toi
on défend l'option leucate
et donc le break mais ce qui va nous
faire un petit fossé à tous fous ces 5
pouces et 5 elle la grande ligne
les italiennes wavre et bizarre qu'il
est fausse ouais c'est bizarre qui
feront que des espaces je continue à
faire comprendre du tout le choix en
fait c'est son choix quoi baver tu vas
dans le truc que l'autre joue mieux pour
être bien sûr d'être moins fort en fait
je n'étais pas assis sur des bancs fort
que toi donc j'ai vraiment voulu tout
faire pour le prouver
je lui ai alors dit en même temps
pourquoi comme ça
ça peut vous dire serait en train de
répéter frénétiquement j'avais dit que
c'est un petit 6 pts en rêve là je
pensais juste arrêté deux roues et
freins je sais la rethel regard des
matchs en fait donné beaucoup à faire et
vous convient à faire on sait de quoi ça
parle pour la peine on fut ce sens par
l'ouragan c'est en parle vraiment c'est
beaucoup il est vrai doit aussi racheter
il y aura plus de noces travail adjugées
pour un indien oui c'est ça en fait plus
rien à dire en fait c'est ça plus aucun
intérêt j'ai toujours dit et puis voilà
mais c'est marrant en fait en les gens
sensés ont juste arrêter de regarder en
vrai
à y regarder à la fin je pense vite fait
comme ça ils cliquent encore perdu la
tête donne une pièce en donc pas de
chance alors hop à lui mais ça
attaque
un signe qu ils font tout le temps ça
maintenant les hastings sa méthode
moderne de jouer
l'idée c'est d'éviter que les blancs
face une expansion à l dame comme vous
le savez maintenant on va dire c'est
souvent et aussi de faire des casses
pour le fou éventuellement pour reculer
et dans le petit point que le dmp vite
damas est qu'on peut voir ici ou là
donc donc ok
le petit asymco
l'orang outan est ça c'est dommage je
peux avoir l'idée d'aider même après bon
c'était pas facile de fermer un tueur un
gambit roi un truc comme ça
mais c'est pourri mais bon au moins
pourri pour fous rires avant tu t'amuses
en tant que spectateur ceux qui ont un
gant d'iroise sympa bon mec se fait
réfuté il perd mais t'as vu quelque
chose quelque chose on sera là c'est
revoir une énième italienne
pour les faits ce qui donnait pour faire
caler deux perfs ou g5 je sais pas qui
ont eu de la joie
mais plus un truc comme joe barak aux
4,5 des cats
ouais
jean plus rien à [ __ ] ça passe devant
les caméras je crois qu'il ya vraiment
super ce à
quoi j'ai déjà vu ce coup je crois de la
part de wesley so mais c'était peut-être
pas dans cette position
bon pourquoi pas parce que tu peux les
rb5 il faut remonter à mars et de aussi
est donc bon voila tu vas tomber sur le
côté tu fais le
cavalier nouvelle quoi
donc ce qu'on ne prenne pas quand il aux
gens ça sert à rien de regarder
ben non parce qu'il ya quand même plus
de gens qui regardent que dans les
autres langues donc ça va en fait je
peux me permettre de dire que ça sert à
rien de regarder parce que en fait
ça reste quand même le le stream le plus
suivi
c'est vrai à l'anglais donc ça va en
fait en fait ça va
on n'est plus suivi que le russe qui a
un joueur en finale depuis le début de
la compétition donc ça va je peux bien
dire que ça sert à rien de regarder
personne me dit rien ce serait bien que
les autres par contre réussissent à
faire que les gens s'intéressent au
matchs un autre problème
françois jacq
sera le prochain à défier magnus selon
nous ouais ça c'est dur à dire
très dur à dire
on saura dans huit mois oui c'est ça
votre en juin juillet
bon alors sur la forme du moment
évidemment c'est
offiront mais pour être en forme à ce
moment là et compte des tops joueurs
donc
il ya une pièce touché bon dans le clip
1 il y en a marre et de tricher tous les
jours ça triche tous les jours c'était
extraordinaire
on va voir s'il ya quelqu'un qui a un
clip
à ça peut être magnifique
on mélange
à quoi en plus peu de regards delà
en fait s'il a de nouveau touché valise
à double ses vingt cinq ans je m'ai
bonfa je pense qu'il peut le faire dix
fois personne ne dira jamais rien
touché au
possible qu'ils le fassent 40 fois dans
le match quand même façon au bout d'un
moment c'est quand même abusé
il vérifie bien que né peau soit pas
pour pas regardé ouais
j'ai touché vont te faire chier
je crois qu'il n'a rien dit c'est vrai
il n'a pas dit jade ou froid
c'est complètement interdite non mais
c'est vrai faut complètement perdu quoi
laisser extraordinaire en fait c'est
magnifique en fait nan mais tu fais ce
que tu veux tu touches les pièces
jointes okapi c'est sur les chiffres à
l'appui aux chiottes qui pisse sur les
pièces
qui doit faire ça peut-être maintenant
par
comme on est un an pour troll non mais
par superstition ouais il faut bien que
je touche pour être pour avoir deux
échecs avec moi quoi
il a déjà doublé 10 mais je n'arrive pas
à voir s'il a dit peut-être qu'il a dit
cela la dernière fois il a vraiment il
avait vraiment pas a dit cette fois ci
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas l'angle de cam
pour bien voir les lèvres ses lèvres
bougent ou pas on peut pas vraiment dire
l'a dit bien que la rendit
leila il a appris les axes mais bon là d
un face à face il y avait que 1 point
d'écart
larbitre aurait fait respecter la règle
c'était plus le même match est vraiment
un carton quoi est il faisait jouer la
pièce était plus même match ô combien de
faire attention ce après deux pièces
touche été suspendu pour la rencontre
suivante et du coup personne pendant
place et ça peut faire victoire sur
tapis vert ville a expliqué le jour que
l'art du risque présent c'est qu'il n'y
a pas besoin de dire si l'adversaire
n'est pas un fin nous on a eu les règles
avec fable autre jour oui on s'en fout
danger et je sais que personne ne voit
rien venir mais la règle est décrite
comme ça c'est pas nous qui l'ont écrite
nous nous ajustons l'icwa la règle la
jurisprudence
jusqu'au jour où il y aura un arbitre à
qui
je sens que tu es une notion de
jurisprudence d'ailleurs dans le sport
c'est pas y'a pas un juge qui est venu
un jour dire un trait de son marteau non
mais tu allais une jurisprudence en fait
dans la loi je pense que c'est quand tu
as une zone un peu grise et que ce sujet
n'est pas comme ça mais qu'après d'état
je pense pas que dans le sport est un
arbitre à maintien l'as tu as droit de
mettre un tacle par derrière
jurisprudence tout bon aloi je pense pas
que tu as un truc comme ça
en droit la règle suffit pas s'il ya une
jurisprudence c'est ça mais c'est en loi
mais dans le sport parce qu'un arbitres
une fois tu fais maintenant la surface
il n'a pas l'heur thiery henry contre
l'irlande
il a passé les jurisprudences thierry
henry marmite n'a pas sifflé loi de
faire des mains bon ben je pense pas
quand même quoi
je pense pas que tt ça dans le dans le
sport
c'est bon qu'on aura dans ce même des
bocks d'habitude que
c'est les mecs matrix et par les séries
américaines attribuent ces familles
c'est avec eric yens bravo j'aime caduff
reste quand il commet de vip objection
votre honneur
n'y a pas des tribunaux d'arbitrage ou
quoi il n'ya pas
échec
enfin en gros nous on a relu la règle on
a repris le truc qui doit vraiment dire
ja double
il se trouve
mais là je crois qu'il l'a dit ouais
vraiment
les médias mme quinn base
je suis très heureux ouais t'as du coup
quand on fausse avons à dire regarde
[Rires]
d'accueil clignote pas le truc un peu
quoi
dans le fond c'est qu'on dirige aussi le
mec est pas là bas non en fait non parce
que si un arbitre il arbitre peut te
faire le pièce touché pièce à jouer
justement c'est pas parce que t'es pas à
la table qu'on fait n'importe quoi
yves agid n'était pas à la table du coup
en matière je fais quatre ans dames
s'étaient pas la tête est pas là on va
être l'arbitré il est quand même là pour
vérifier quand tu pars de tâches est ce
que les règles soient bien
appliquées donc la règle étant la règle
du jade où ils vérifient que les joueurs
touchent pas les pièces pour faire des
variantes c'est normal en fait
c'est pas m'attrister jusqu'à nouvelle a
expliqué que ça se faisait comme ça même
si ça respecte pas strictement la règle
oui mais en fait si un arbitre un jour
qui vient de faire respecter la règle
parce que c'est la règle tu vas dire
quoi ah oui mais personne ne la respecte
comme je respecte pas
non mais enfin
hier un jour 1a ravi c'est comme sow qui
écrivait sur ces parties des petites
annotations ce focus whistler bon ben il
ya des arbitres son laissez passer qui
ont laissé passé qui ont laissé passer
puis un jour tu es un arbitre qui le
diamant ta partie perdue en fait tomber
leurs auteurs t'as pas le droit de faire
et puis ou sso il s'est pris un forfait
dont il avait la jurisprudence que tout
le monde le faisait bon bah un jour il
ya un arbitre qui arrivent et qui le dit
bah en fait non toi t'as perdu toi t'as
perdu ben il n'y a pas de jurisprudence
et a perdu ses prix forfait dans la
gueule à vous maintenant une autre plus
rien maintenant il n'en fut rien en fait
il l'a fait pendant des années et puis à
un moment donné un arbitre puis
maintenant d'ailleurs il joue même plan
donc ouais
les arbitres il arrive il arrive qu'il
fasse respecter les règles
il va plus dans un avertissement si tu
as envie de vous en avez donné la partie
d'avant front il a conçu la partie
d'après et bim
ok mais jalouse c'est pour dire
attention je vais pas jouer cette pièce
là le mec est pas là mais non mais c'est
pas fait pour ça c'est fait pour pas que
tu touches les pièces jadoul c'est pas
pour dire aux mecs attention je vais pas
jouer cette pièce c'est pour pas qu'ils
puissent toucher les pièces
m facile à comprendre au bout d'un
moment
mes fans je sais pas vain
sinon tu pourrais tripoter toutes les
pièces regardez un peu les solutions à
tiens si je fais foulée 5 ça fait quoi
et puis tu remets tapia la cale le flou
sur ses 4
c'est pour pas que tu puisses pas
tripoter les pièces
c'est une règle c'est enfin je vois pas
le problème de cette règle soit pour que
les gens soient pas d'exister existe on
fait passer comme le fou qui bouge en
diagonale si demain tu arrives et que tu
dis moi j'ai envie de bouger tout droit
les mecs vont te dire non non mais pas
facile arbitres te dit rien ah tiens je
vais te faire [ __ ] en celle-ci se
dégage avec ton cahier je vais doubler
les pions et fit que le mec décide à
bâtir moi je fais tout reprend on va
beaucoup plus fort que moi
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible de
toucher les pièces sans dire jade ou non
plus face 0 but d'avancé car
je ne peux pas comprendre en fait c'est
une règle c'est comme ça
si on pose une pièce
ou pas
on demande d'ajuster ses escadrons
médailles comme il faut mais là comme il
faut
c'est ce que nous faisons a doublé son
four je sais
donc
tu commences à balader les pièces au
dessus de l'échiquier en disant jadoul
1,90 utah juste la remettre tu fais pas
ce que tu veux
bayer faut pas trop adoubé parce que
j'ai juste reçu notre ex ne pas trop
regarder son adversaire
gênant pour lui donc bon c'est à double
une fois une pièce ça va ce n'est pas
très bien placé donc quoi mais si chaque
fois te fait que toucher tout temps
jaloux et genre à double jeu radu budget
de le faire un bon ça suffit qu enfin
merci que rubinstein way mairie se
cacher ouais faut pas déranger pour pas
déranger et se cacher
votre cacher
ses terres il risque la liste à peu près
par timidité maladive peut-être
individualités comme des pots en fait
une petite trappe grain
lijour et défie la salle de repos
une langue officielle aux échecs qui ont
inscrit mais c'est peut-être le français
français d'où déjà
doublé
les prises en passant devant les dix
membres pas sans
ambition sahara sans imposition la
pollution de corne et aussi qu'on
travaille krishnan
howey cinq mois
si tu as un gant techniquement tu nous
tiens je ne touche pas les pièces et le
gant qui les touchent c'est ce que je
veux monsieur
ça pour essayer une fois est ce que l'on
considère comme c'est à main qui est
interdit c'est toi qui touche
une marionnette quoi c'est dû
avec l'automate oil automates
auxquels question de tichy lots
qu'est-ce que j'ai manqué au bar rien un
pièce touché bien ce jeu on sait pas on
hésite je pense qu'il ya déjà du pain on
pense mais voilà le moment important
pour cent de ce début de partie
sinon juste bon voilà on a vu une
italienne c'est un petit changement par
rapport aux espagnols
globalement voilà
en 18 minutes de jeu
pour bientôt la douve et quoi
tu seras aucune pièce
et cette position peuvent terminer
l'espagnol par transposition
difficilement ça doit être possible si
on fait rarement exprès de
puisque tu peux faire flouer 5 à 6 ou 6
kg qui classe 5
complexe
vraiment af qu'à deux minutes pour aller
pisser vous en pensez quoi non je pense
que tu risque de rester quelque chose
non prendre la petite bouteille d'eau le
bidon à côté je peux pas te permettre là
où tu me regardes ton téléphone et
peut-être fait partir de toiles est avec
moi sinon
attention ne pas le faire tomber quand
même dans une cuvette la cuvette ouais
bien sûr excédent vote
après si ton téléphone
est
étanche waterproof ouais ouais faut
alors le maître bon du riz ou déjà
prémuni rameutant du riz dans les
chiottes
d'héritage suite que
je suis prof et actrices
comme la justice de vaduz quoi
ça c'était beaucoup mieux
peut-être on doit pas faire et que les
blancs ça h 30
on dirait un truc ça viendra après peut
faire des g5 et comme ils ont parodié
fonds g4 et ils ouvrent tout et voilà
as tu as vu le cam la prison et de 100 %
chez les blancs
partie parfaite faut que ça s'arrête en
fait
et là paf h3 non mais je crois pas je
passe ici dramatique mais bon j'ai 5 ne
fait jamais trop plaisir c'était un
grand prix font g4 et douvres la
position et c'était un bon après que me
l'a déjà fait à 5
non mais va faire autre chose j'ai
recueilli ces deux ris tu veux jouer le
gain c'est pas mal mais moi j'ai tu
provoques obligé de faire rire mais
peut-être qu'il provoque
pourquoi le système de londres et peut
jouer à haut niveau bas parce que c'est
pas
parce qu'on joue ensemble pour le coût
relativement peu joué quand même femme
oui mais plus qu il ya dix ans
et beaucoup plusieurs annonces étaient
mais moins qu'il ya 4 5 ans ouais
une petite correction au niveau du
système de londres une correction
précède je pense on devait être repartir
à la hausse possible
sk et touche le support
important
le cifor
qui est de 4,25 pour cent deux parties
dans l'année je pense elle passe sous le
support après tout s'écroule en train
d'en tu voir que ce système de londres
du tout ça c'est dangereux cannes
un petit sondage je peux choisir votre
palpitant suspense insoutenable au monde
elle est outrée en garde une partie
invasive mais si ce suspense
insoutenable
explique lui aussi aller un petit h3g 5
que magnus la colle et que ce soit
terminé c'est parce que je pense que il
ya vraiment beaucoup de gens qui
espèrent bien que le toit se termine on
voulait pas me voir ça une bonne fois
pour toutes
si fine exil
et moi pourquoi j'existerai
[Musique]
tout tout tout
et
je sais pas trop ce qui allait sûrement
qualité de jeu d'érable sky b5 allez on
va rêver un petit coup juste comme ça on
serait content à manger le fou en a 7
mais bon il va bouger et puis ensuite
ensuite tu vas nous faire cavalier de 7
et puis ces 6 et puis on va à rebours
jusqu'à et b5 qui sera pas pas tip-top
peut-être donc qu'il y avait cinq ou six
coups d'épée dans l'eau
h3 bas j'ai peur des g5 moi perso après
peut-être nevo peut le faire le temps
pour avoir une position qui bouge
voilà et
baky siret d'accueil c'est le cas
normalement faite
pour ça que je prends prochain fricassée
de
la cheminée ne laisse pas travaux de
piment
ouais on a beaucoup parlé ya plus grand
chose à dire on a un match samedi c'est
demain c'est un match dure un peu
dimanche vous ferez un débrief
si ça dure pas bon oui on joue à reims
un concurrent direct un bon match très
important for sale champagne c'est de
roga bonito
donc on a viré pu l oms à l'adjoint loin
d'eux qui a été promu je viens sablé qui
avait déjà fait quelques matchs en 2017
et un peu la cata et il jouait bien lu
nan c'est un milieu il était milieu de
terrain capitaine de l'aca se
prononcer bien passé malgré du du pays
bong et marseille mais il a grandi à
saint d'élèves sa carrière ici quoi et
après la main un petit peu joué à lens
et bastia je crois
initiée niçois et
ben pourquoi pas une main discours assez
c'était pas mal sa conférence de presse
il donne le brassard de capitaine à
castries
ils nous écoutent aînés pour bravo ou
pas d'ailleurs je passe c'est bon signe
mais et je vois la voiture et les pas de
grandes pompes qui ont tiré ils veulent
un nouvel entraîneur qui arrive
c'est pas logique mais en même temps
bizarre parce que je me dis bah si tu
vends le club à noulens tisseur
peut-être le mec qui va venir avec un
projet si tu prends mon entraîneur dit
descendre tu vends le 5 janvier ils
vendent le 5 janvier non c'est moi qui
ai d'une date comme ça c'est mon
anniversaire je vois c'est un beau
cadeau au quatuor du monde club ça fait
plaisir donc j'attends aspirent les
nouveaux pierre ses murs mais oui ce
sera possible en fait on sait ce qu'on
perd on sait pas ce qu'on trouve mais
bon voilà je sais ce que je perds mais
je veux dire
quand même y ait des chances de faire
mieux il a vraiment fait ni sébastien ok
je pensais
bref voilà le petit moment et c'est ce
qu'on verra en tout cas bonne conférence
de presse de sabella pris quelques
petites décisions il prend ses
responsabilités et change le brassard
tout ça puis on verra on verra samedi
après ça se trouve si samedi tu gagnes
le match 6 ha tien bazille on laisse un
peu sable et il peut finir la saison
même en fait je me dis bon sur 5,0
encore samedi capitaine c'est un gars
formé au club m'a dit camara
moi je trouve pas génial techniquement
mise bas d'hier il ya une bonne bonne
mentalité mais
je suis pas super fan du joueur on va
dire
c'est toujours bizarre dégâts concernant
l'effectif mais justement je pense que
ce qui se disait c'est peut-être lui
pesait ce côté avant le brassard parce
qu'il est un peu jeune et peut-être
qu'ils se dispersent et trop et ça sera
bien que ce refus sur le jeu et et tu
laisses un mec d'expérience comme tout
cas zurichois
égard il est pas un peu fou fou fou fou
fou mais au moins il car il équipe enfin
on imagine déjà que dernier exactement
excuse moi pour ce mode vous battez
dernier imagine sipa labonté quand même
dernier mais mais plus loin qu'un
simple
jeu de mots femmes oui je sais mais en
plus ça se au delà du genou
l'entraîneur il a fait quatre matches
peut être fin 2010 est peut-être pour
autant de défaites qu'enfin m'a pas
laissé un grand souvenir mais depuis
tout elle a fait ses diplômes il a fait
adjoint il a un peu à priscilla machin
donc on va alors si la cuvée 2021 est
mieux que la cuvée 2010 est
généralement ils jouent avec à cuatro
après non dans ses positions pour bien
fixer le truc et faire cavaler à 5 y
aller choper le fou c'est quoi c'est à 4
dès que vous prend 1,7 et d4
libé pour avoir floué f1
red star ledger décédé cinq noms
donc on peut évaluer ça est-ce que la
tour est trop mal placé ou pas
l'autre toujours un dieu singe à une
réticence entend ses positions au blanc
ouais
t'as des cinq je sais pas
en tout cas oui c'est moi c'est moi un
prêt lundi que si le plus rastan bloqué
proposer des bons
parce que le fond à cette info actifs en
fait il est passé devant la structure
donc c'est plus un mauvais fou il serait
mauvaise il est en deux sets mais comme
il est passé devant les pions il a
obtenu une diagonale il n'est pas moins
fort que le
blanc est aussi faut dire ton fut certes
c'est pas trop le mettre
dans des deux bons il fait vraiment rien
en c1 il contrôle des cases mais en fait
ils gênent un peu d'atouts rein ou quoi
donc en trois finales membres
par la force des choses à la presse tu
te fais prendre tu perds contre comme tu
réponds jamais aux fourneaux du cavalier
mais mais des fois on voit des pulsions
prend voilà c'est bien débile mais mais
ça peut arriver mais non tu prends du
cavalier sattler aussi que tu viens vers
f5 liens vers des cinq dons qui n'est
pas si mal c'est cavalli ici on n'a vu
d'avion galère bien pour les amener là
dans les dents les espagnols donc il est
pas si mal placé
et
et voilà donc forcé clé noir n'a pas
forcément envie d'échanger par toi même
il faut trouver un coup utile pour deux
tours 8 elle favorise autour de 8 heures
mais bon c'est un peu mieux pour les
blancs comme toujours
perturbé
les noirs trouve la manière propre
d'égaliser en fait
exactement
c'est théorique encore nom de parti
je pense fait que rien ne pouvait être
pire que ces anti marshall
bah en fait sur le papier c'est pas
problématique mais comme personne et
hyper bien préparés qu'ils jouent très
très bien ça le devient en fait on
auprès du pape sûr que là on est plus
commenté marshall non mais je vais
reparler que vu les styles et tous à
l'impression que
je vais pas faire moins que dans l'anti
marshall en fait voilà ça c'est pas trop
bien passé pour dépôt ce choix
voir magna se trouve à cames grande mais
je prendrais pas sa place est
peut-être le a4 comme tu me suggérait
peut-être
peut-être est-ce qu'un tour 8 est
jouable
très vite pourquoi pas cavalier saad
saad dont le ranch des coûts acceptables
j'imagine pour pour les vergers si ce
qu'on a déjà vu plein de fois et aussi
des fois pour libération c'est donc il
ay la multitude de choix jacques riou ça
tours 8 pro 3 4
ouais faut juger quatre moyens je dirais
mais c'est peut-être quand même jouable
mais point de sougé 4 c'est que ce
clouage sert pas à grand chose donc les
blancs n'ont pas fait des quatre parce
que tu
vas tu m'as serait un bon tu fais un
clouage certes
3 il touchera le fou donc ça fera perdre
encore un coup or pourquoi je 5
c'est moins grave c'est le califat on va
dire ah bon tu te fais vraiment touché
de porto et 15,3 kg 3
ça apporte pas grand chose aux
marques il faut poser une question très
intéressante
c'est mieux d'aller faire autre chose
perso
et du coup de garder du temps pour
regarder des parties qui sont vraiment
vraiment cool toi femme mon avis
bon je te dire fais comme tu vas pas
raté grand chose si tu regardes pas quoi
après il faut passer la prière avec nous
on peut discuter voilà à faire des
leaders des grands débats sur le pièce
touché sur sable et entraîneurs à
6,8 à la pub à regarder aussi et c'est
déjà l'heure donc mon pour tout ça ça
peut valoir le coup prêt pour la partie
en soit
je sais pas trop t'es pas sur
tes même pas bien sûr je suis pas très
sûr
dans la pub la pub va peut-être relancer
l'intérêt à
plusieurs une question intéressante
après de
god je pense qu'on va vendre après la
pub pour pas que vous manquiez question
du coup c'est peut-être une petite pause
avec la pub aller 5-1 manquerez rien
ouais on est de retour
qu'on a absolument rien rater c'est
parfait
n'a pas raté le moindre coût mais stable
bouffe au bon on a eu peur quand même
on va attendre que ça joue qu'est ce que
tu veux faire d'autres m'ont fab ou
alors la question d'europe ce code qui
demandait s'il ya des joueurs de foot
pro qui était fort aux échecs on a déjà
parlé de agde stein
qui bat qui était longtemps le meilleur
joueur norvégien plus de 1600 et l'eau
est qui
qui est grand maître qui était
international aussi d'enrichir de foot
donc pas mal et si non alors dans les
joueurs français actuels
je savais que genre comme anne je sais
pas trop ce sont les loups coin mais il
jouait sur deux chaises comme on avait
vu
des photos quoi c'est pas mal il ya ben
arfa ceux qui jouent 18 ans jouant donc
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal du tout donc
voilà certains joueurs qui jouent il ya
un onglet aussi ouais je crois que c'est
arnaud lallement et à le gall le serbe 6
jeux les jeux reach l'apame battre en
plus haut
s'est beaucoup impliqué
avec son album ça
le mbc passé les droitiers ou gauchers
mais pour cause d'échec c'est pas trop
grave
donc ouais non il ya des joueurs et des
joueurs
et puis après je pense qu'il ya pas mal
comme vikash dhorasoo qui qui joue un
peu
et cetera donc il ya des gens qui aiment
bien ce jeu le joueur de foot encore pro
ou axopro
moi la question avait il ya des joueurs
d'échecs bonbons foot - paraguay fan du
joueur d'échecs dans ce sens la plus
difficile je crois que c'est plus dur en
fait ouais en vrai
bon mvl joue pas mal on a vu en vidéo
ses talents quoi et papou ici
genre d'échec fort en foot plus dur
marc-andré avec bar quand il joue il
joue là pour l'instant mais
vraiment ça sera dur peut-être de faire
les deux très haut niveau quoi on va
faire un choix mais oui par un petit
niveau par exemple dans les grands vins
de france aille axel qui veut pas mal de
larmes et passé par centre de formation
un peu il joua valmalle mais enfin je
sais pas exactement jusqu'où ils jouer
correctement quoi mais disons maintenant
son niveau c'est qu'enfin déjà il a
fait pas mal ouais je vais pas mal
d'exemples
bon on est une petite série de coups les
fous de cases noires sont échangé le
petit tour 8 comme d'habitude
à 4 pour bloquer oui on s'attend à vous
aussi ce projet pourrait changer encore
un petit fou
bien proche dé galles
et à gagner qui faisait chaque aussi
ça alors il en est où
je crois à la fois j'arrive dans les 700
800 ça monte petit à petit c'est bien je
sais bien
c'est qu'ils signent là nul qu'on soit
lisse yvon bibere nous quoi c'est
magnifique
ouais bon l'instant vraiment infosys on
fasse du fou pour l'échangé
penser que se sont parlés avant pour
faire 3 nuls je pense pas mais après
dépôt par rapport à
masse d'argent quand même assez
importante qu'il a pu avoir en
sponsoring qui peut pas se permettre de
donner le match
qui donne l'illusion au moins mieux
jouer mais s'il croit plus trop à
faire des turbos draw turbo drogba du à
10 minutes
est-ce que des nuls peuvent arriver dans
un match entre l'allemande abbas est
arrivé il ya trois ans dans le dernier
donc c'est possible c'est même plus que
possible
oui je vous passe on va tous nés peut il
a rien à perdre parce qu'il a déjà perdu
en fait jusque là rien à perdre ce qu'il
a déjà perdu
on n'est plus au niveau du rien à perdre
là
pour lui un
bon autant la partie qui paiera la
longue partie fait des erreurs mais bon
admettons mais après des deux autres
c'est un peu donné quoi
complètement amené sur le roi et fuite
machin bon genre pas compris le fou
prend enfin forme et ça ça mais c'est 5
qui perd une pièce sa cage et il en sera
encore avec un seul point de retard il
aura encore de désespoir les e-bonds
j'ai deux parties avec les blanches peut
tenter avec les noirs d'être j'arrête à
petrov un monde dans une position où il
ya plus de jeu et tu sait jamais mais là
bon trois points c'est comme
l'ascension que ma news ou encore en
gagner une ou deux arrêts ça va être
difficile parce que si l'on gagne le
match s'arrête
donc axa est durement gagné 2
compliqué
c'est par un gang sur la dernière
blanche donnée pauvres c'est sûrement
aujourd'hui la dernière blanc fait donc
oui c'est bloqué le pont avec le kef
trop deuxième coup dommage
sinon père c'est possible en magnus peut
perdre une partie si l'on gagne le match
sera quand même terminé en fait
il ya six ennemi dès qu'il ya cet ennemi
il a gagné une victoire c'est un point
c'est ni plus un set et demi
complexe fab
votre musique avant dernier ou dernière
partie avant dernière
avant la partie chais pas trop l'avons
tournure des événements ne prend pas de
grands risques voilà et
onu le probable on va dire vu la tête de
la position après peut-être un léger
plus pour les blancs fin peu apprécié
que les noirs mais bon ça magnus on voit
qui est bien concentré dans son match il
n'y a pas de raison qu'ils se mettent à
craquer maintenant oui du coup pas du
coup voilà
[Musique]
comme dit non
moi je sais pas de quelle couleur
franche bayat peut-être on n'est jamais
à l'abri d'un nouveau c5 bah oui ya fait
ça peut quand même juste perdre mais
c'est pas un dépôt ont un emploi parce
qu'il a fait était très concentrés bien
assis bon là pas trop
je pense pas qu'il ait envie de re rga
fait quand même
essayer de faire un peu le taf
peut-être un petit quelque chose
pis des blitz ce soit en espagne
ouais je sais pas
possible un saucisson espagne et j'ai le
droit de jouer peut dire fr le blitz
c'est beau c'est pas une seconde pas
loin
d'après ce que j'ai le droit
après source ou bat na waie sur pareille
la vue qui a une info comme ça qui est
lâché
source ban
on va voir si nous lâche la source ou
six rabanne des fins
ban osef des sources
oui si c'était le coup logique et
peut-être fou et 5 la
wave et ça il faut 17
très beau dessin il faut 17 pouces et
quatre faut aussi
non plus je pense quoi mais bon je
commence à s'opérer quoi sources
s'inquiète frère
sur ce montant ils échangent
c'est suite à ce qu'ils fassent tout ce
qui
vient de prendre
ma news qu'il reprend avec la tour très
bien twitter
plutôt ardu qui twitte part de qui ah
ouais mais là s'il n'ya pas le twitter
de kiss & band f1 ces mots reviennent à
chaque fois il est sous archiac irak
plus sous pression tout de suite ouais
donc même détrôné par un compte twitter
avec deux abonnés
intacte plus haut
des sociétés
mais pas toujours obligé de défendre il
faut regarder les enfermements dame de
là il semblerait pas un puisque tu en
avais dit la dame français 6 donc bon il
va falloir défendre ce pion au miam
c'est bien sûr pas des six mois
à moins que
vous êtes aussi un cavalier cette dame
prendre cette gare d'etterbeek donc
peut-être même dès sinko
l'armada
cette fenêtre une défense
en souplesse
j'aimerais bien voir sa source en fait
je suis complètement bloquée par par la
source qui tombe pas
pour voir un
il ne donne pas la source et ça ira
cache peut-être qu'un milliard de tweets
les cinq minutes
tu veux te comptant 20 ou pas mais je
pense à yoann français antoine dupont a
été désigné meilleur joueur mondial de
l'année normale vendredi le tricolore
recevoir la distinction
qui étaient les deux précédents je sais
pas danser un quiz mais j'ai pas les
deux précédents gp l'a vendu tous je
pose comme ça
jared harris à
15 heures debout rakesh c'est quoi ces
rakesh quoi etc et salanque ou 15 il est
tard hier
à cacher que le carnet ou je sais pas
quoi
en fait je suis pas donc
dr galtier 10 à dusautoir waits
autorités pierre roy aurait pas dit
galtier moi non plus j'ai pensé blanco
et oui peut-être mais d autres arrêts
avec une photo a été montré en 2011
quelle belle coupe du monde et des fins
dommage cette finale 1 contre les blacks
[Musique]
il donne pas sa source en fait ce qu'on
lui dit twitter tu peux mettre un lien
du tweet qua
non mais il parle pas du tout ça twitte
des trucs de tout de rien
[Musique]
et tu te montre une vidéo de copland sur
les cinq coups les plus brillants andy
carroll sur che score parce que sénateur
di caro ou ailleurs c'est à dire fait
hier un
le hc le sg et oui tu es tu sors le rsi
pas de son segal mythe aurait
annoncé quelqu'un qui parlait le
championnat du monde de blitz et rapide
en espagne après il dit source twitter
et ses vastes qu'on va chercher plus du
tout
abba retrouves retrouve sinon bah non ah
bah ouais mais bon celui-là je cale des
grosses infos
jacques chirac ça des infos à
première vue
premièrement vive
et surtout confidentielles
je suis un compétiteur je vais voir fait
très attention
non
une source au quai à cet argent
tard jeudi suis quand même
oui mais ça peut être bailleur spain
d'android poteau de shell houston
rockets ses potentialités
monde dubaï on avait
l'espagne
ok ok bon t'es pas tepa vannetais pas
bonne presse n'est pas lui qui a mené la
source a énormément
quand bien même il l'aurait dit source
evian
et qui s'est confirmée bas coup de
chance mais ça marche mais l'espagne
vont faire comme en
espagne a pas trop de restrictions au
fait on
jette un oeil
l'espagne bat linares a peut être
pas vaste l'espagne où est-ce qu'ils
organisent des gros event en général
linarès mais j étais ya pas longtemps et
n'a ainsi pas une si grande ville mais
bon quand il y aura de personnes
centaines ils peuvent avec l'espagne
puisque regarde la courbe qu'ovide oui
ton très bien assuré ni sont très forts
ah ça monte ça monte de folie et du coup
comme c'est dans deux semaines et qui
devrait faire le pic est arrivé dans
deux semaines je pense que j'ai de votre
chanson des voix une chance que ce soit
a pris ouais ça va être le petit revient
à laisser vos faits s'ils vont hisser le
pic va vraiment être dans deux semaines
quoi
justement du championnat du monde c'est
extraordinaire brest et autres de
chercher des olympiques du à lafitte va
aller là bas et c'est en plus ça c'est
parti pour pique
je sais pas bros sur le mans 3 1 jusqu'à
quand est-ce que son parti pour pic
c'est magnifique
c'est peut être la ville où il ya le
plus de cas penser madrid je pense avec
madrid 1 bat du coup c'est l'autre à
madrid s'annonce
déjà annoncé ma grasse sud de l'espagne
c'est la race et c'est peut-être grâce
c'est plutôt dans le sud un ca à côté de
madrid non non c'est assez sud
vers séville cordoue par la balle à
rennes tout
les questions commencent à arriver en
espagne ob c'est magnifique j'ai
conservé en espagne les restrictions 1
c'est magnifique brassard et espagne
alors c'est sûr terrible
non mais c'est sur un
os suivre sa bombe et 6 en espagne et
que j'ai le droit de jouer pourquoi pas
franchement et faire le bien pas un jour
levis façon ces 29 39
c 26 27 28 le rapid ses 29 38 buts
mais c'est quand même fou de ne pas
savoir deux semaines avant fin juin les
gens vont vous vers valence peut être un
cheval en somme cette jolie ville quoi
ben ça
parce que tu auras 6 quand un coup de
merde pas tu défends ton pions
après mal placé et à tour aussi s'il se
fait caillasser 4 on s'est rassemblé 6
as tu as toujours un peu à l'ouest donc
ce n'est probablement pas le meilleur
mais
c'est pas absurde
non pourquoi je sais pas quelles sont
les conditions en fait c'est pas un
tournoi open où tout le monde peut jouer
il te met lots minimum ou quoi ses 2500
s'attache peu fermé six mètres de 1600
non
voilà
déjà je pourrais sûrement pas joué à
cause des récessions et l'au delà de ça
non j'ai pas si je peux si je peux
prendre deux jours c'est pour des
vacances un c'est pas pour aller jouer
encore des blitz passé
est-ce que benzema on sait pas de bâche
mais si vous voulez pas jouer mais non
mais le fait son espagne ça peut donner
envie du coup un truc tu seras jamais
fait partir au kazakhstan époque mais
jouer à côté des plus rapides le blitz
non
donc ces gens pensent pas
25 ans sur le site de la fidh c'est trop
pour moi
mais bon je voudrais laisser manger ce
que je ferai mais ce nombre est en jeu
samedi 26 et 25 avril ont dû
entre les deux journaux mais une
dérogation que quand même mais t'as pas
va t en rapidement
en fait j'ai quasiment pas de classe ont
joué quasiment jamais joué des tours ma
fille dans rapide au but parce que quand
tu fais les rapides en france souvent
ils sont pas classés d'halloween jasper
certaines comme celle player arrêté
d'atlas 25 finir eating cessa jamais
championne représente england
ap to finish une paire eurchf travaux je
peux travailler par la fidh peut-être on
va voir ma vie c'est dur je pense qu'ils
invitent
des joueurs de pays qui pour participer
et 6 soit je pense qu'il ya rien pour
les blancs la non de ce truc
je m en 1
et donc du coup d'autres trucs gérant
ces caïds et cinq ans tu peux pas
prendre pendue qui le souhaite peut
maintenant ça a l'air d'être bien
également
pas mal hein c'est bien de bien c'est
bien
non pas 25 58 quasiment 2500 j'ai perdu
un peu des points là quand j'ai joué mes
tournois un peu plus récemment
après normal vu que j'ai pas fait une
once d'entraînement depuis un an et demi
pour progresser mais n'y a pas de souci
là dessus pour que non non pas de 25 50
ans qui aura pas de grappa de bleach du
coup
peut-être que c'est encore mieux que les
fans du coup
à non ça va être dur
alors ils ont plus de cas
complexes
il fait chaud la vente souvent en
espagne mendois de voyage en espagne pas
trop je me rends compte le doublage
surfaces super chaud mais ça doit aller
enfin on se fait genre van hummel qui
peut nous dire s'il fait chaud à dubaï
tous les deux le wc - les soeurs de la
pub en plus 23,2
donc donc t'es pas mal en fonction sera
plus dubaï caisse par une personne ce
que tu aline tous les joueurs à qui va
avoir des visas pour l'espagne
et élimine quand même tous les joueurs
non européens en fait non mais la fin
ils sont un peu dans la merde c'est
notre galerie dans deux semaines il
vient d'annuler leur truc qui te sens tu
penses que tu trouves et puis tant pis
genre non européens battre en pillages
plein d'offres
or mars annonce louis
faire plusieurs tonneaux à dubaï tout le
maroc
et le qatar c'est doha c'est ça
ouais
pumain si je n'obtiens pas qu on fait
une petite pause des amis on se retrouve
tout de suite à tout
sarah les amis on a encore fait une une
pause bien senties on n'a absolument
rien rater fable c'est magnifique
entre une tour au centre est ont vu
leurs cavaliers set je pense
et des 5
je ne sais pas que faire d'autre
satwa la maison
au 8e tour à la maison
à
demi nue ramener la coupe à la maison ah
ouais
ben vas-y avoir
des six co ça doit pas passer non pas du
tout
il ya aussi dame 17 rue huit noms ouais
pourquoi pas de sauter un coût
raisonnable
alors très bien parce que les blues vont
rien faire des quatre nous vous le
rappelle plus tard le problème c'est
qu'après pions prend bien on prend
qu'elle allait prendre enfin il y aura
deux pions et quatre en l'air donc
problème hausse
du coup pas si simple d'avancé faire
l'expansion le
central pour les blancs
c'est officiel c'est en pologne
qu'auront lieu les world graphie des
billets l'espagne dit alex vers son
moteur c'est pas une fac news mais lien
ou ban procès terrible regza sont
peut-être qui peut avoir une bataille a
pu rhône qui vient de away prend la
magnifique j'ai presque envie de te ban
pour la fox news de tout à l'heure
fidèle à pete wentz de fall en hausse
trop rapide au portant
à la maison aussi quoi ils vont pas me
sais jouer quoi je leur écrirai ok je
m'appelle libye chef ski quoi les gars
quand même quoi
tu aimerais bien en pologne ou pas bah
ouais franchement
savard saut c'est bien
d'être sympa quoi pollution la de
l'année mais j'aime bien la pologne
enfin voir les quatre copines jeu pourra
découvrir quoi
il va faire froid
à bananes vous
savard saïdi marceau france à varsovie
effet devant les cages du coup je
regardais kako vite pour voir si ça peut
bien bien bien confirmé
au
lavaud pic en cours à sens pas bien il
sent pas bien la pologne c'était sur la
maison bien regardez l'espagne ça montre
c'est pas mal on est bien sur la short
list dubaï non beaucoup trop plat
pologne oui les résections poèmes
polémique à la progression atteint
qu'est ce qu'ils disent bon ça intéresse
un petit peu au sujet tient effet
cavaliers c'est toi
le port du masque est obligatoire les
espaces fermés bon ok donc de trois
jours qui gâte houara conditions de
résiliation avec 5 physique est donné
sur la pandémie sont consultables du
gouvernement il recommandé
actuellement tous les voyageurs qui
viennent en pologne des pays schengen ou
de la turquie ont l'obligation de
présenter un test pcr ou antigénique en
polonais ou en anglais
le résultat a été obtenu pendant les 48
heures précédant l'entrée en pologne
dans le cas contraire ils seront soumis
à une quarantaine de dix jours
cette espèce r c'est paraît il faut
faire tester sélection polonaise way ou
en anglais oui mon polonais mieux
reçoit 10 / sont dispensés de cette
obligation les personnes vaccinées
combien de doses ayant reçu le nombre de
doses requises pour une vaccination
total j'imagine c2 les personnes qui ont
terminé leur isolement du hac
internationale les enfants de moins de
12 ans et diplomates et leurs familles
attention à partir du 1er au 17 décembre
2021 la quarantaine pour les voyageurs
venant d'un pays de l'ex heures de
l'espace charnière passe de 10 à 14
jours avec possibilité d'en sortir avec
un test négatif au bout de huit jours du
coup pour les de détection de dubaï
faire gaffe s'agissant du variant au
micron une quarantaine obligatoire est
incompressible de 14 jours est imposé
aux voyageurs devenant 17 pays africains
mozambique botswana afrique du sud jesse
fait brûler
les autos et les sonnettes un vivier
zimbabwe
oui en fait oui bon ils sont pas bien
parce que d'ici le 26 ils vont durcir
les
chalets en fait c'est comme partout ça
va mieux le début
donc je pense fouet arrivé le 28 pour
jouer le championnat du monde deux
litres non c'est bon quoi tu pars
maintenant un vol demain que je vivais
quoi vous le décrire la fidh cas lors
des rebonds
est ce qu'en tant que français d'origine
polonaise le droit de jouer
en fait est d'origine vraiment lointaine
non ouais un petit peu enfin combien de
générations
c'était mon arrière grand père qui était
polonais est loin mais
j'ai jamais mis les pieds on peut n'y a
pas une fois pour prendre un avion
j'avais une correspondance
tu vois c'est peut être l'occasion quoi
a été beaucoup plus loin que moi de
l'italie en fait pas but à cannes
n'était pas loin mais gérance
en arbre généalogique aussi
mais bon il doit faire quand il fait
quelque la température à cette période
là parlons tous intéressants ce live
help line hi d'affaires
bien faire zéro quoi
j'ai pas je vais faire regarder météo
marceau il fait 0 - 2 - nature j'ai bien
senti quoi jeu après ça dépend janvier
en décembre en russie peut faire ça il
peut faire moins 20 aussi
cette jolie à cracovie
attention pluie verglaçante en fin de
nuit
il fait pas terrible
je suis alors il fait moins froid il
neige voiture et on n'est pas parfait
mais c'est génial je
crois c'est à kg ce pas logique les
trois
existantes sur place même les serveurs
parfois qui s'ils n'ont pas de masque
sur ce jeu via cracovie source crois-moi
frère je viens cracovie ton gun fight
with no fake wii
s'offre héros j'y suis en ce moment non
mais bon je veux bien le croire matin
oui mais bon ben il a pas de même on
veut bien mais pas
sur lui pour cent
un passage au tour pour revenir un peu
en 18 ans 8
30 kg
dames c6 aussi qu'il peut rêver après un
message aux dames 17 ouais bon c'est
vous dans le même rêve c'est un ordre de
coûts il veut peut-être un peu tape h3
quand il fait kg 6
mais bon c'est vrai qu'il ya une
possibilité de confinement la barre
haut mais peut-être encore mieux il ya
peut-être une possibilité de clusters
géant
sur le temps adlis
de rapides encore mieux magnifique
maxime d'amd s'inquiète un coup
impossible un
nom on cherche des drones tout d'un coup
comment ils ont annoncé un peu dubaï
dont s'est passé vraiment le sens un
clic un peu d'espagne et finalement ils
ont clic
graco enfin varsovie ne survivrait
pas franchement souffrait hyper plaisir
d'y aller tu peux y aller de faire le
nouvel an là-bas
enfin un petit coup de pologne dans mon
avis c'est bien quand même classé
l'occasion c'est l'occasion ray
voilà c'est l'occasion veut y aller mais
tu part peut-être le 29 ou le 30 noms
ont beau se joue pas pour le 31 même
temps va être pas annonce qu'il faut
peut-être que sir et a besoin d'un test
d'un truc d'un machin
pour mieux assurer le coup
est parti sur le 29 depuis monde suisse
a joué que j'ai le droit pour je ne sais
quelle raison coup de chance pour
le bit
c'est possible qu'ils te laisse le droit
dans le sens il va pas y avoir grand
monde qui va jouer non plus tu le droit
bordel non mais peuvent avoir enfin
la paille avoir masse de joueurs n'ont
pas on se bat
elle n'est pas la partie la plus
emballante de l'année 1
oh
non mais bon comme dit maxime b 5 c'est
jouable ils peuvent faire d'autres
éléments
des petits coups
les seniors on aimerait bien faire des
cartons n'avait pas du tout
j'arrive pas à faire marcher même du
tout genre de 30 des petits rendez de te
battre à fond mais bon tu as de prendre
des cinq toi même nom c'est vrai
nom adam b5 mais je veux bien faire
tourner vite j'ai pas envie d'échanger
expansion
non ça c'est pas m parce que si tu fais
bab a traversé quatre en première
un peu plus sa faiblesse et si un
échange labatut captura passait alors
ses petits trucs
après faut être un peu apprécié que les
noirs vote leur dit alors ils s'en
foutent ils s'en fichent exactement et
donc tu fais des cinq ça va quoi
pas les plans ils sont simples pour les
deux joueurs ans et je veux des 4 et des
cinq en gros
mais juste c'est ni possible ni pour
l'un ni pour l'autre
groupe a
en bessin qu on peut tu peux après ce
pionner un peu pénible il va si tu as
des rêves et du cavalier ex terrain mais
tu peux toujours c'est vrai qu'après si
tu fais tourin b4 toi même avec les
blancs il faut tout voir la colonne et
faire des petits trucs
pas grand chose mais un peu quand même
et puis l'autre il est peut être de
faire ces quatre pour tout bloquer venir
à calais en d5 tu vois jamais trop de
faire manger parce que tu feras s'éprend
toi toi la colonne c
est un
tas dé petits plans avec les blancs les
noirs un peu moins un effectif de
inattendu mais pourquoi pas moi
je sais pas j'ai pas femme carla jeu
s'inspire pas le truc hyper dangereux
quand même parce que tu perds la la
pression sur le central à oreille va
peut-être cavaliers j'ai 4 mai
la tête du death in court maintenant
mes voeux cavaliers âgés cavale et prend
pions prend peut-être
il veut peut-être ça
ça n'a pas l'air très dangereux l'un
des 8 kg 4
c'est pas ça quand même pas l'air ultra
dangereux dont
5,9 je sais pas trop ce qu'on va faire
de toi
même kiev 5 peut manger tour des six
fois lors des six
se passe pas grand chose
se passe rien en fait
mais vraiment c'est vrai
mais bon
voilà quand tu joues ça tu te poses des
questions justement sur les dames b5 que
je prends je prends pas quand je fais
des 5 t'as pas de question de pose en
pratique après à regarder c'est vrai
qu'on est là ouais
c'est vrai que ça avance un peu plus ou
moins que la collection
très clairement mais c'est assez logique
qu'ils réfléchissent venir c'est pas
toujours faim les coupes à tous naturels
meta parmi tous ceux très bon mal de
coups naturel certains qui sont moins
bien qu'ils lâchent un peu des choses
donc il faut bien choisir quand même
c'est précis ouais mais après à regarder
c'est vrai que c'est
bas de deux choses l'une la partie en
soi
bon ok c'est pas une grosse partie
d'attac ou quoi mais ça c'est la
deuxième du match mais quand on est là
c'est qu'un match est plié donc en fait
mouais moi vibrant qu'à bayonne une
partie comme ça avec de l'enjeu c'est
sympa mais sans enjeu du tout c'est ce
que l'équipe eut mené au score 3 0 85e
qui s'approche à 30 mètres des buts
adverses ils s'approchent s'approche
copains
c'est pas pareil quand il se retient pdf
un petit décalage que la russie dégâts
rien du tout non vous une passe en
retrait machin bon
le retour du petit rock 'n' afat pas les
parties ouais je pense c'est vrai que la
création du petit rock a vraiment versé
les échecs fab d'ailleurs pour ça que
krainik veut supprimer cette règle elle
dit que sa révolution a vraiment de jeu
elle a fait un match contre nantes qui
était très suivie gros coup dur pour ce
match sans et donc éventuellement
peut-être qu'effectivement ça pourrait
être la solution très bonne remarque
c'est vraiment une belle idée ça
redonnerait vraiment la vigueur au jeu
ça
paraît que ce serait beau
celui sur à quoi la solution à tout en
fait
je pense à supprimés les pions ça peut
aussi être une idée avec sont les pions
déjà des changes les dames c'est le
premier coup la tête c'était bien je me
plais tour l'autre si tu vives doute
c'est sympa
ça clique un
coup franc que les blancs doivent être
un peu mieux mais
si tu prends des vite tu prends je suis
tu profites paraît chaque lot très mal
quand il d'abord
réfractaire
mais bon c'est intéressant on aura des
victoires on a plus de victoires
va supprimer les rois
c'est une idée aussi
du coup on supprime le rock par la même
occasion très bien des heureux quoi
donc on faisait ça crame nick
belle partie en tout cas
donc
du coup vannes oc a fléchi dans
sa va cliquer un rouleau à dix coups de
toros un petit coup de kay g6 je sais
pas pas mal de coups logique
[Musique]
parce qu'il choisit
des habitants les coûts
c'est logique inquiète
tu fais des cinq égalisant force à
viande et 8 pour former le petit dessine
co et c'est bien aussi pour cette tour
aussi lorsque à ceux des six sata et
qu'elle regarde je sais pas ça c'est
peut-être pas un mauvais coup mais ça va
pas impressionner sa peur quand même
bien le contrôle du centre
tout se joue sur le carré magique on ne
sait donc là forcément un coût un peu
d'animaux le passé quoi
gérer les g4 et qualifiante à l'orangé
quatre
opposants un échange d'un échange alors
est-ce qui va l'accepter ou pas ce que
c'est du coup de magnus carlsen
d'échanger des cavaliers
je pense que oui mais ce qui va échanger
lui même ou se laisser changer
question intéressante mais échange elle
permettrait aux jambes ramener option
vers le centre m
cette conception est dans un bon
contrôle d'accès f5 mais les noirs pour
être peut-être je vais des cinq à ce
moment là faire leur révolution et
finalement ouvrir cette colonne des
ramener la tour aux six ans je serai
pour être une idée
car tu penses à
quai les ponts c'est bien
donc se refuse l'échangé que tu es vite
quand même ses passifs
la nul n'est pas loin de là nul n'est
pas très loin là je pense non c'est bien
pour pour magnus qui se rapproche du
titre on sait qu'il ya 6 ennemis il faut
cet ennemi deux nuls ça suffit une
victoire ça suffit
voilà nul avec les nord après dan afin
la prochaine avec les blancs il sera il
sera très tranquille pour fermer le camp
nou
ça a échangé des ça c'est ce qu'on avait
vu depuis le début en verre
vraiment les coups les plus logiques à
un magnus au noir
oui on dit
la seule heure mais n'atteindra pas le
coup de manu sont à voir si je suis
minute ou deux après c'est à 13h01 il a
pas joué le couperet tombe un abbaoui
la magnus il est pas stresser le savons
c'est que même si tu perds en fait
encore battu perdre avec les blancs
faute
est vraiment pas stressée elle a en fait
fuiter t'as pas une mauvaise position
tient même pas de raison de
ce qui se passe dans la tête de magnus
un bail calcul dans basic itunes
étrangers kadhafi se laisse manger et
quand est ce qu'il fait des cinq
objets des coûts des chèques
mais là ils jouent pas fab
je pense pas comme une victoire des
noirs aujourd'hui on aura encore une
belle partie demain
on se disait quand même c'est dommage
d'en avoir ce week-end a pu peut-être
aller se balader à faire des choses
ça par désespoir ces attaques à mossoul
à quoi donc que oui nul gain de suite ça
fait très plaisir magnifique
à tout à l'heure on viendra on verra si
minus échanges ont été changés ou quoi à
tout à l'heure
alors on est de retour et sa clique ou
sa clique est parti au centre et
s'inquiète des quatre et ça va cliquer d
échange massif non
sabbatique ed ou alors je déjeune et je
pense
que l'idée 5
des quatre noms way j'imagine déjà
la clique prise
10e tour des grosses recrues hockey
at war 4 et oui on est quatre échanges
sur hbo machin est
déjà ce pays non mais wayne mc 4 du clou
un peu à droite à gauche et qui les
prenait 5 sera non
bon ok hélas à 110
à 8
tours de danse et c'est tout ce temps
les autoroutes c'est tout
ce qui compte comme ça le [ __ ] clic et
cycliques en d4 clique de
84,4 t1 s'est vite clique des contrats
clément fait pas de carte 4 mais
parfois ça qu'est ce qui se passe
d'autres dont les sondages avec clic 4
la d45
g3
kata russie
bon il se tord ou quatre qui passe un
jour niveau mais bon c'est pas
impossible un vrai moncontour des
siciliens soucis avec le khalife 5 après
on cherche nokia sur la tour mais
si la tour 4 ça peut faire ça et ce
qu'est une deuxième option
dans l'autre sens entre états d'âme
parce que ça s'est joint
aux bouffes cahier c4
le dessin est peut-être m'en donne des
trois peut-être encore mieux c'est pas
si mal pour les noirs du tout donc
ok bon je crois qu'il a les deux autres
champs et mutuellement lorsqu'on voit
un garçon qui avait deux options faire
nul
très loin là
il aura fait une bonne partie un
magnus solide un
n'épaulera jamais réussi à le mettre en
danger dans le 4-5-1 ans il a fait son
nom le laisse pas mal
avec maxime ça a été plus dur pour
magnus non
c'est pas enfin ces femmes et
visuellement après bon je dois dire que
ça a été dur de faire pire que ce café
dépôt
france en été mais après c'est pas bon
jeu bon je me faisais rien c'est pas une
époque et un mauvais joueur il a juste
raté son match hélas après n'importe qui
peut rater son match c'est une certaine
pression car de jeu un match du
championnat du monde mais ces excuses
pas qu'on peut être déçu et qu'on peut
prévenir bas mauvaise prestation parce
que c'est le cas
mais sans même rien au mérite de donner
podor a été là et voilà donc je dois
dire que n'importe qui dans phases de
vénus pourrait souffrir de la même
manière à la gare et s'énerve c'est
injuste envers néo pop suis doué maxime
est plus créatif ou quoi fin non mais
faut il vraiment fort
de
là il est vrai mais là vraiment mal joué
à 7-6 7/2 enfin fo ça devient pas un
débile pour autant et
voila mail a raté son et raté son
tournoi
mais on sait pas ce que 15 autres aux
effets et probablement
voilà après on peut dire la cigale et
autres à deux passes ratées plus dure
pas ça c'est clair voilà caruana
problème en irai pas raté puis
l'habitude carey akingbala d'habitude
aussi mais il est calme moins fort donc
je suis pas sûr qu'ils tiendraient un
second match à faire égalité non plus
quand même donc c'est dur quand même de
se frotter à karl scène pendant trois
semaines comme ça ban et pau il a bien
tenu au début mais c'était peut-être pas
la bonne stratégie et enfin a priori pas
une stratégie de juste jouer pour tenir
et s'accaparent des monts magnus et
monte en puissance si tu la fais à
longues parties saluent ce fait imploser
en août quoi et après c'était fini le
match a duré cinq parties quoi
maxime il aurait pu faire un bon match
vous faire un mauvais match mais voilà
on va vous dire c'est sûr où c'est pas
sûr en fait mais je n'ai pas il s'est
quand même qualifié pour les candidats
il a gagné les candidats fin il mérite
complètement d'y être a boy peut pas
donner et critiquer avec son jeu mais on
peut pas non plus dire qu'il a rien à
faire là enfin il ya tout à faire là il
voit lui
mais ce match live oui mais il a mal
joué c'est tout
il va falloir faire des nuls mais quand
tu as gagné je suis pas sûr bajard sont
qu'en partie longue les dernières
parties de maxime contre carlos et noir
c'est quasiment que des défaites non
chez pas trop les dernières baies
contre car la scène c'est pas ça se
trouve maxime préparé six mois de
trouver un truc vers le répertoire il
peut gagner lâche aussi enfin gens
peuvent inventer toutes les histoires
aussi et ça c'est sûr mais je leur
parlais que visuellement
mais oui bah si le match a lieu tu ne
dis pas je suis pas favori mais après
après on joue on se bat on fait ce qu'on
peut
attention que je vous dise car c'est
notre favori contre n'importe qui en
fait donc c'est un peu le problème
n'est pas ses qualités ses défauts dans
ce match où il est passé à côté il est
passé à côté point barre ouais c'est ça
en photo ça aurait pu arriver à
n'importe qui
n'a pas fait semblant de passer à côté
mais ben c'est fait c'est fait et c'est
chrome sac alors après peut-être
quelques serait moins passer à côté ou
quoi mais
on ne peut le savoir
refleximmo réussissent à se qualifier
aux candidats déjà on va prendre les
événements les uns prétendent les uns
après les autres et dans l'est dans le
bon ordre
bah c'est déjà la priorité du moment
c'est de se requalifier une fois qu'ils
étaient requalifiées bah c'est pas mal
si tu connais un peu la marche à suivre
maxime les a déjà joués du coup il
pourra mieux appréhender le tournoi
sans vraiment de pression en vain une
pression normale mais pas qui écrase et
puis prendre sa chance de travailler ce
groupe d'amis point il est pas loin donc
bâti ce à quoi
il est passé à côté comme les cocons de
kram n'ai pas l'impression que l'écho
des cris du peuple passé à côté de son
match dès qu il a fait nul contre année
qui était devant avant la dernière
partie on est passé à côté de sa
partition
évidemment ici le flux à carreaux cannes
mais il faut dire aussi que cramique a
fait une bonne partie
ivan n'était pas simple non plus de
faire nul dans 100% des cas quand avec
la rencontre amicale époque
donc non quand tu finis le comte kramnik
sur un match tu peux pas dire tu as fait
n'importe quoi
c'est quand les prochains candidats mans
on ne sait pas non mais bon hiver juin
juillet pendant oui on sait pas on n'a
pas la date précise du tout tu vois
comme ils déplacent les trucs les dates
les machins
magnus qui cherchait option
web et de regarder de manière de prendre
et choisir la plus précise qu'on a un
peu regardés assistée par ordinateur les
ventes qu'on vous montrer juste avant
donc la priori prendre délicate très
bien prendre le cadre ça a l'air d'aller
aussi croyons que plus précis c'est
prendre des quatre prises des 5 et tours
4 faut bien tout calculé ça peut
nécessiter un service de qualité avant
qu'on a vus mais qui doit ne peut
sûrement carrément gagnante pas si dur à
voir voilà
bien sûr évidemment est encore une heure
quasiment à la pendule donc il a bien le
temps de tout vérifier et voilà
il a l'air très tranquille oui
rapidement avoir quelques coups quand
même fab je pense que d'ici une
demi-heure la position devrait se
décanter oui devra la servitude 2000 on
a une nouvelle pub avant bien laisser
décanter
saleh
après ça
ma vie encore une bonne heure et ça va
se décanter
pianiste demande sur les stades non deux
défaites de kersaint drogue ces
dernières années il a bien failli en a
pas tant que ça et je pense que notre
pression est bonne il était dans sa peau
d'où il déjà ils perdaient pas pendant
longtemps et après par des contres
d'audace et ça
en lente il a reperdu une autre ou deux
autres et mais oui dans l'ensemble il ya
très peu perdu
you can't immense et apprend à peu près
deux heures ça des quand moi je pense
une heure une heure et demie ce sera
décantée ça va aller assez vite ça
dépend aussi de la carafe hmmm ça va
aller vite maintenant pas à partir de
mars est parti
je pense vraiment trois heures de jeu
max mais je pense que
une heure une heure et demie ça décanter
peut-être entre deux et trois heures de
jeu à partir de maintenant c'est mon
pronostic voilà bah ça surtout je pense
sur la main gauche je vais réfléchir le
temps de prendre sa décision et après ça
va un peu prendre prendre prendre dans
tous les sens et
ça peut aller très vite mais ça veut
vraiment aller vraiment très très vite
dans deux heures on est peut-être plus
là
pour le ski
repro réfléchi en général son joueur pro
ou pas est-ce que tu dois réfléchir
c'est tu détermine
des coûts candidat dans la position donc
voila tu as vu il y avait une masse de
pions au centre tu pouvais prendre dans
un sens dans l'autre ne pas prendre donc
bon c'est plus dur ne pas prendre quand
même donc battue commence par regarder
un ca sont eux pas de sourire en même
temps tu analyses et donc pas et même
les différentes reprise des blancs donc
ça fait un arbre de possibilités et tu
essaies de delaune un jugement sur la
position tu te dis ah bah ça ça va je
suis bien ou non ça va pas [ __ ]
schumann je peux pas jouer ça m'apporte
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il faut le
jouer après tu regardes l'autre coup que
tu avais regardées l'entreprise tu
refais un jugement aussi et tu compares
et tu prends celui qui va te semble
mieux d'après d'après ton jugement quoi
donc là faut jouer tours 4 en plus de
l'avoir ici relève quand même beaucoup
c'est naturel est revenu au galop
magnifique
voilà donc c'est beaucoup de calculs et
de comparaison de variantes mais c'est
pas que regarder un truc longtemps c'est
tu dois un peu réalités différentes
options et choisit celle qui te plaît le
plus après là je te dis quand on
réfléchit en partie lente fréquentant
blitz il ya quand même pas mal
d'instinct tu vois un truc qui t'as
l'air bien tu as peut-être pas le temps
de regarder 50 autres est ce tu rates un
truc encore mieux battre en pis
et puis ça dépend aussi du temps que tu
as là pour nous ça tu peux le faire en
début de partie à la fin quand on sera
it not tu es un peu en mode blitz donc
c'est aussi différentes la gestion du
temps aussi à avoir est aussi tes
objectifs dans la partie et dans la
position parce que si tu juges que tu es
moins bien c'est une vente qui fait égal
qui finit en ul battue peut dire ok ça
c'est cool dans l'autre sens c'était
mieux tu vois nantes comme ça tu
l'éliminent donc voilà oui très bien
bravo magnus qui joue la séquence
précise
et voilà ce qu'ils jouent les parties de
12-13 machin sinon quand le jour où manu
c'est que les champions il est champion
et ça s'arrête on it pour égard il a
parlé le match aujourd'hui en fait je
sens une gaffe positive donnée pour oui
tu vas pas tout est changé donc cela qui
forcerait je sais pas il peut forcer
devenir complètement fou il est
complètement résigné je sais pas mais a
vu comment il avait vu ce qu'il fait je
m'attends à tout ce que ma nuit ici joue
vraiment bien et jouent bien ils jouent
très précis sf trois hommes à ce contrat
mais je pense que le destin de ce match
et qui finit sur une gaffe une de plus
qui reflèterait vraiment
le match en soi l'app la partie se finit
sur une gaffe qui reflèterait l'ensemble
du match
parti très sérieuse de cartes c'est nenê
peau qui implosent serait beau pour
l'histoire coire turin
f3m pas faire f3
mais bon c'est vrai que c'est du niveau
de ses cinq en fait
deux
donnez pas aussi j'ai ainsi déjà ce nom
j'ai prévu des trucs en fait parce que
j'imaginais pas que matschiner a
aussitôt toute façon mais pas envie
après dans un autre monde où j'aurai pas
compter du tout ici j'avais mois de
décembre libre pourquoi pas mais j'aime
pas considérer le finalement la
possibilité
tu veux plus jouer non
content d'être sympa en plus reykjavik
je serais content de jouer s'il est
maintenu bien sûr et il al'air maintenu
mais je vais pas jouer autant de jouer
avant de faire 150 partis pensent à ça
c'est sûr
ça va être un peu rare des matchs par
équipe à voter pour moi ici
même à sitges ah ouais non mais tu vois
je peux faire des vacances en soit je
suis très heureux de faire des vacances
derrière en général
lord mc2 sandra regarde et hearst et
3,95
[Musique]
sur tora fiat faut qu'il se ressaisisse
qui prennent en d4 quoi ou qui il enlève
son cavalier peut-être est-ce vraiment
des quatre
l'esprit de prises précise prise tu
france s est tu prends des quatre
bien également ouais ça peut faire ça
mais
en fait famille les pas pro
[Musique]
c'est pas un joueur professionnel c'est
fini cette époque
c'est super une vie d'être pro échec on
sait bien mais qu enfin l'ag plus haut
niveau enfin
j'ai déjà fait renaître se gagnent
beaucoup
plus ma vie en proportion avec les cours
que je donne les commentaires
et dvd les choses comme ça que mes 40
ans dans la salle je dois dire j'ai pas
fait de tourner depuis avril 2020 quand
même donc forcément avant et gibraltar
en fait on attendra janvier 2020 après
je fais quelques matches par équipe au
quad ici et là mais
est donc oui enfin moi je me concentre
plus du tout comme trop quoi
comme jeu repro je fais d'autres choses
qui ont rapport avec les échecs
passés ça joue un peu on clique
près j'espère on espère toujours essayé
de faire pas trop mal aussi a tous un
côté compétiteur qui restent mais dire
j'aimerais bien même ça que
ce que je
pas envie de perdre c'est chiant
et fo la juge accepte on voit je perds
je perds c'est pas grave ce sera très
bien oui
on essaie quand même de jouer au mieux
organisés mais si on perd on perd j'ai
pas encore j'ai pas encore des tâches
je l'aide en intellectualiser
niveau émotif non
je devrais je sache bah oui mais j'ai
pas j'ai pas ça
tu veux comme métier au quotidien bah
écoute bah ouais c'est ça je donne je
donne des cours les commentaires des
choses comme ça
il faut que je prépare des way des
vidéos en course peut être lui délivre
une époque la bombe n'a plus trop mais
qui ça
sert à quoi
je pense tu penses qui peut déconner
large et 3 et oublier ce serait mérité
après tout le temps debout comme ça
dernier craquage bailly peut il pleut il
pleut il pleut il peut faire le con bien
sûr il l'a déjà fait dans le match après
c'est un coût serait un nouveau une
nouvelle fois un coup indigne de son
niveau mais qui sait ce qui peut le
faire
ouais bref je souhaite pas je ferais tu
allais fier de fait à petit nul ça
une dernière gaffe femme
battue lui souhaite pas
c'est pas lui souhaiter c'est une
dernière ouais ouais c'est vrai que ça
donne un petit samedi libre c'est bien
aussi quoi pour la route fab une gaffe
pour la route
mais jure il est tout le temps debout il
n'a pas du tout changé son attitude il a
gaffé aller faisant une dernière avec
toi
le câblage cette poupée vaudou
une dernière
ils peuvent faire elle me paraît dur à
faire qu elle va mêler a fléchi en fait
réfléchie il va pas faire ils veulent
qu'on en dise grande que tu sais pas
à deux doigts
pour prendre quatre c'est normal ça
change tout voilà
il a vraiment rien obtenu aujourd'hui
insipide pire que
je crois que c'est la pire de toutes
avec les blancs heureusement qu'il n'a
pas philippe etchebest d'analysé chicane
dans son équipe un beauf étoilé chéquier
tu m'a servi avec les italiennes de
gémenos et vous cueillir et voir ses
fichiers de prépa il faut des fois ça la
poubelle quoi
je reviens mais je veux te voir tout
jeter
jette ses ordinateurs et ses disques
durs
ces prépas périmés
mais ton et devant une foule ni
ordinateur quand je marche en chine
je pars sur l'échiquier ce serait beau
j'ai jamais vu ça
les prépas aussi dégueulasse j'avais
changé 3 elle va justement c'est la
faute qu'on attend c'est j'ai trois
options - cavaliers
puis on prend tour dames projet quatre
échecs il aurait super faible
c'est un peu la crise as pour les gens
ça c'est un exemple de crise as mais bon
ça illustre bien le problème d'avoir un
droit qui se baladent plus de pions qui
défendent le roi est déjà une dame qui
vient ici ils prirent un cavalier en
renfort la tour crise par des six plein
de choses comme ça donc voilà
en trente ans de carrière
ah oui c'est bientôt la pub ah bah oui
à voir que je vois reçoit chier bas
sillage et
3,6 à pages et 3 vont quand même pas
et pour mener contre manu son parti dont
il est battu avec des antilles marchand
a minima du conseiller de 12 ans
ça fait longtemps parfois que la voiture
j'étais battu au moins quatre ans
ne savait pas jouer moi oui
en fait il avait rien en fait la clique
au hasard niveau variant de principal il
avait enfin seul coup
mais ça devrait se décanter femme assez
rapidement cette place a déjà concédé
quand tu es en fin d'article oxygénation
quand même la décantation
on espère tous ce g3 quand même
j'aimerais bien qu'on sache le nombre de
personnes qu'on a perdu pour les
compétitions africaines sont venus voir
ce match championnat du monde et qui
reviendront plus jamais
international pas en français
alors je sais pas si
si ils seront perdus pour de bon mais ça
que ça n'a pas forcément donné envie je
pense à pas mal de gens où qu'ils ont dû
découvrir les échecs récemment et qui se
trouve à redire je me du monde on va
regarder
qui résiderait bon
lui 5 mins paroisse bon je crois que
c'est une des pires audiences soit la
pire du championnat et puis non
en fait je souhaite à beaucoup de gens
qui viennent un peu pour tous les
tournois chaque fois c'est pas
intéressant
les gens qui restent ici me souviens
mort mais après ben pas cela vraiment
semble aussi ça va mais
mais oui j'écoute début il y avait
marqué deux fois plus de monde quoi il y
avait un petit intérêt et puis mon sens
un avoir je passe mon chemin
j'avais fait la coupe du monde ou à la
coupe du monde c'était cool
voilà la forme a déjà beaucoup mieux et
puis en plus comme vous on l'avait un
petit peu expliquée en amont c'est qu'il
fallait suivre à partir du troisième
tour et du coup il y avait deux trois
matchs sympas mais bon ça avance et puis
ta deuxième nation à chaque fois elle
est invaincue dans le tournoi de son
jeune adversaire c'était cool
d'abord ridicules pour les pubs ah bah
oui c'est vrai que ça m'a d'ailleurs
sa part merci burnley c'était prévu
cette annonce est bon à la pub à
permettre de bien bien tu sors quand un
peu plus on va tout de suite les gars à
tout
il a dit que j'ai trois lega pro c'est
extra
on est content la pause 9 ans
le petit recoud quoi sa paire instante
magusi grimace comme le jour robin
incroyable
alger trois ces normes et niveau sur la
demande déposée 2003 max en lnh croit
que sa faim depuis la route de 6 c'est
catastrophique les cinq premières rondes
ok c'est pas tout le monde qui peut
faire ça quand même mais depuis
amellal à cette partie là c'est vraiment
1800 1900 max si tu fais pas g3 tu
prends des quatre généraux mais comme
tous âges et 3 c'est que luc hees qui
n'a fait encore [ __ ] c'est magnifique
quel match champion du monde
extraordinaire des parties longues pour
être bien sûr d'avoir de la qualité
saluant des heures et c est plus faible
que
alors juste question et on va se trouver
à toutes les variantes possibles c'est
qu'ils ont prises f4 d'alger 4 alors bon
bref un nordmann damage 3 re 2 e
dans le pro tour des six soirées autour
des 6 yakuza des
retraites ok donc important de prendre
la mesure en histoire d ici soit à
tanger si c'est plus d'un projet si
l'arbitré intervient attention
puisque what else
3,3
wells heureux de bouffe ne pas prendre
bouge sa tour
assure qu'il prend des cinq de partout
autour et vite hyperfast à votre hotte
c'est hyper facile
bon vin néo pros qui
[Musique]
fâchent quoi dire en fait
je comprends pas
non mais le problème c'est que la partie
est dure deux heures et honnêtement sans
troll j'ai joué des blitz juste avant de
meilleure qualité en 3 + 0
enfin pas oublier purger trois tubes aux
hommes sacrifiés je m'en fous mais tu en
partie longue c'est grave mais même en
blitz en fait c'est dans le règne des
partis moyennant vite ça va quand même
beaucoup de bruit depuis ya pas de gaffe
non mais mais là c'est vraiment passé
vraiment même pas 2002 orne son gain le
niveau bombe à ses cauchemars
c'était quoi le titre cauchemar soit
choqué
ouais bon que je pense aussi mais c'est
vrai j'aime l'info
mais c'est beaucoup et à réviser encore
une vidéo pire partie des belles
histoires
et c'est bon il aura fait vraiment des
belles parties d'aider des bottereaux de
séquoias quoi s'est classé de l'arbre
devient bien combien je connais son très
grand mais
c'est de la belle galette
mais c'est incroyable ça donc
l'information cette manip champion du
monde et comme je l'avais prévu il a cet
organe 11e 12e partie maximum maxima
vraie preuve là il avait vu tout juste
un peu ce que 11e parti a peu de gens
qui l'avaient
faut vraiment un carnage pour perdre aux
sites web non c'est vraiment humiliant
incroyable c'est vraiment incroyable
andré
va jusqu'où on va tromper mais c'est là
là c'est vraiment pas ce que c'est je
pense c'est ouais le pire match champion
du monde de l'histoire du jeu en fait je
pense même stein hissé sous carter
savent mieux que ça doit de voir des
conneries mais pas aussi régulière mais
c'est terrible en fait jouer moins bien
et xu carter tu sais
mais ça fait mal en fait
en plus aujourd'hui on n'est même pas
des supports nepos et l autre fois quand
tu vois ça faisait de la peine pour lui
mais il recommence la même connerie
chaque jour ça va c'est assez
extraordinaire enfin on pourra dire au
final on pourra quand même se dire grâce
à cette gaffe qu'on aura vécu le pire
match de championnat du monde de
l'histoire du jeu et sans laure a vécu
ensemble les amis et
du coup
on a vécu l'histoire a vécu l'histoire
way
est une qu'akon le g3 à bages écho à
louey mais en fait c'est mérité
cette partie à l'image du match mais tu
gardes tu as même attitude de merde en
fait levé à tous les coûts achat nature
fait de thélème coup de mer en fait
c'est mérité
mêmes causes mêmes effets ouais même
conséquence pour la 9 qui n'en a pas
fait autant de gaffes contre l'ask r non
je 9 qui j'ai revu un peu le match
c'était moins pire en fait même le pire
match de l'histoire
c'est dépassé un salon avait eu de
record dans ce match la partie la plus
longue et le match mais après il faut
considérer que tu enlèves les coûts
d'ouverture parce qu'ils les connaissent
par coeur mais bon ok ça tu veux pas
pour comparer tu enlèves des coûts
d'ouverture hors ouverture en fait née
pose c'est vraiment enfin ouais même
même manar personne ne faisait moins
bien mort fille joue mieux aussi n'en
faut peut-être retourner sur des joueurs
de type là pour donner pour pour avoir à
peu près six niveaux de jeu philidor
machin ça joue un peu comme ça quoi
huitième siècle quoi
mais on leur a vécu ensemble quand même
dommage mon manuscrit clinique dans
l'exécution c'était pas très durs
magnétiques qui rate pas le roi va
bouger va prendre un f2 soit hors
apprentis lads soit dame prend un tour
qui débarque et ses ouailles à faire
reuzeau je pense mais bon
c'est pas intentionnel
à 20 mètres s'il veut finir la partie
vite fait rage il fait le truc qui perd
le plus vite on fait s'il veut finir
vite
justifie nul quoi tu te reprends des
cadres machin tout le truc on a vu tout
symétrique
donc je sais pas
je
parce qu'il fait en fait
vers le roi et fuite super énervés de la
petrov l'autre jour c'est inexplicable
nos échecs c'est juste que tu en tilt et
que tu veux totaux punir que fait un
truc mais le team d'henri finit un jour
ce que je voulais dire le fasse c'est
comme quand tu joues tu me lis tu fais h
4 h 5 h six autres au premier coup et
t'en fais pas tu fais pas que ça à
chaque partie en fédérant tu te prends
aux teintes
sait que la partie vraiment à l'image du
match mais pour rien obtenu avec les
blancs il a gaffé c'est vraiment elle
appartient vraiment à l'image du match
c'est ça
c'est vraiment pas digne d'un mâle
championnat du monde après c'est cool
pour nous aussi c'est un des pires
spectacle d'offrir mais vraiment
non mais enfin
mais comment tu veux faire c'est le pire
spectacle possible
selon son suspens et se joignent à
l'ombre d'un suspense à joue mal mais
bon les parties longues très importante
ici c'est vraiment là qu'on fait la
recherche de la vérité on va une
nouvelle fois vous j'ai raison mais on
se trompe des tronçons mais c'est chiant
d'avoir raison pendant 20 ans et les
mêmes trucs
ça se termine aujourd'hui ouais voilà
quelle gaffe de dépôt et la purge du
match quand même le fou bessette wayne
on remarque ça c'est ça c'est faut être
vraiment nul pour pas avoir sa queue
basse as tu joues tempo tu veux pas voir
mais quand tu réfléchis tu vois quand
même
nom mais juste il acquit là il a craqué
mais ce qui est bien fait c'est que fait
il à garder cette même attitude de se
lever à tous les coups d'être nonchalant
sauf hier avant-hier sa part entière
mais bon enfin c'est normal les échecs
aïssa l'a puni quand les échecs ont puni
et ça c'est plutôt cool
on
mais
pour le good rhin magnus rien de mal à
dire il a fait son taf il était très
attentionné
qui voulait pas revenir demain
[Musique]
ba qui existent je me au tournoi sg
est vraiment
à ça peut être intentionnel je sais pas
juste une vie volée son week-end
libourne et popular puisqu'ils arrivent
dans ce match c'est que là en fait il
peut jouer telle option par les deux
tours de 6
non mais là les bombes il sait que son
titre il joue pour penser à celle
exercée pour le public c'est vrai
mais le sait s'inquiétait pas fait
exprès je comprends pourquoi là ce
serait plus fait exprès c'est 100%
intentionnel je suis pas d'accord
dessinant abondamment
pourrais tu veux perdre juste abandonne
tout perdu et a pas je tape à jouer mal
quoi
ça serait beaucoup moins sur le faire
chier
tu veux perdre non tu ne perdra pas
non plus je fais trop drôle parce que tu
fais d'euros aujourd'hui demain tu fais
turbo d'euros c'est fini on en rira le
plus tu sais que tu vas faire là demain
sera pas long ça fait aucun aucun sens
de faire exprès de perdre
oui
prendre le vélo chaque jour et en prend
un peu plus cela se répondent c'est à
dire que la gérante de 1700 live
4% là évident et 28 61 mètres à 28,65
mais plus encore il pèse 73 il reste
libre 5 mondial malgré tout
[Musique]
mais sûr que mentalement il a affecté
qui peut juste vos échecs ça c'est sûr
il a pas réussi à se remettre dedans est
tout c'est comme ça c'est la vie
mais c'est vrai on s'est beaucoup qu'on
a annoncé qu'elle soit vraie partie de
faire
voilà c'est vraiment des gaffes que tu
vois plus au dessus de 2002 normalement
un menacer non mais dis plus avant
tellement sonné
à un moment tu peux te reprendre
mentalement quand même que tu craques un
jour deux jours enfin c'est
ce que tu penses à la position va bien
se décanter la
whey voilà c'est bien décantée dans ce
concept même limite trop
léger goût de vinaigre aqua domitia j-6
autant quand même
je l'assuré de quand même on ne sait
jamais
je suis maintenant à trouver quand même
je g3 et jeanne on s'est quand même
passé quand même beau
personnes votent son record des jo en
gagnant ici non
il pourra battre son record à l'avenir
n'a pas le batman en tout cas il est dû
à plus de 2800 80 c'est énorme mais la
remontée à 2865 c'est aussi vraiment
énorme
la chance sur rennes mais c'est sûr que
c'est être en vain mais après ça va
faire du bien ça va permettre un petit
peu souffler tête du coup de main après
demandeur un petit elfe têtu enfin
pouvoir souffler
on peut marcher on peut faire des choses
mais ça va faire du bien à tout le monde
mais wayne n'est pas ça fait mal pour la
et magnus qui savoure c'est vrai que ça
reste quand même long parce que tu sais
que c'est fini et ça encore quand même
duré une heure près
ça peut aller vite pardon une pro f 2
pour des six ans en fait le problème de
d'un bref deux tours des six avants
oui mais il ya quand même pas te faire
d'alger d'auteur juste à me prends pour
qu'on ait envie de france
inter-le ça
c'est quand même étrange
ça valait 1 491 n'est pas donc ça joue
quand même pas mal détrompe toi
bah oui enfin
une bonne partie quasiment sur pièces
comme anglais ils sont en train de dire
que c'est dommage pas pouvoir voir on
tient à voir des matchs de si haut
niveau car ça finit aujourd'hui mais
quelle blague c'est vraiment dommage
mais c'est vraiment dommage quel dommage
on aurait bien voulu voir g3 c'est ça
hein croix et suit encore bien comme il
faut savoir ils sont incroyables en fait
vraiment dommage
le monde d'aujourd'hui mais rend
complètement fou c'est vraiment dire de
la merde tout sans un essai ça tout le
temps partout et
c'est pesant en fait
sans que les blancs sont mieux bah déjà
c'est pas possible s'il ya qu' il ya
déjà nul près nord avec dame échec
damashek d'un échec là ça va un pion
prends tu peux pas faire trois points à
dammaj les enfilades tu vas faire dame
prend et tour des six peuvent empêcher
tout rejet 6 en fait tu vas voir une
dame de moins dans deux coups
sam ce qui dit que ça finisse à une fois
sa mise reims et justin a plus
d'opposition mais lui s'en remet en
cause à ce qu'il a fait lui damien jouer
en fait comme d'hab stresser un peu en
début de match et c'était un vrai bon
après après montera en puissance et lui
n'a pas fait bien fait mais il a cueilli
sans réserve chaque fois qu'il a pu il
la détruit psychologiquement avec ta
partie longue et puis voilà qui n'a pas
eu un niveau où pendant un moment mais
il a été très solide je sais prépa il
était très bien en place et puis quand
il a fallu collecter et ce à la barde il
a été précis là encore aujourd'hui fait
une très bonne partie magnus
se dire c'est pas si dur mecs qui la
joue et c'est très bien quoi donc bon ça
me laisse pas sa performance
particulièrement
non pas dans les premières parties kf5
qui joue à votre cou mais qui a l'air
fort aussi alors dit très heureux donc
il veut faire cavaler h quatre cavaliers
f3
est sûre
surtout reprend je vous fais est né à
tours après
le truc
il dribble pas si simple jeu c'est pas
bon ça ça a l'air très bien ce qu'il
fait
sans plus je fais retour des cistes au
résistant qui est dame prend tour
peut-être qu'ils pensaient loin le plus
clean de gagner c'est très bien aussi là
n'est plus à faire comme l'autre partie
va se mettre à réfléchir 20 à 30 minutes
ah non monsieur je suis sentie devenant
sa
valeur de ce qu'il a fait la fille est
la pièce la partie a duré une heure
encore
j'aurais jamais compris ce match en fait
selon qantas images ou et après tu veux
quelques coups tempo pour abandonner
mais en fait lui s'accroche une fois je
sais pas je
le match est très particulier quand même
elle choisit pas trop le moment idoine
pour réfléchir et
au niveau peut-être tandis que c'est
vraiment ça mon goût kf5 fall autre
valeur juste super clair et ça c'est
bien mais c'est clair aussi un an puisse
se concevoir c'est une position une
belle position mais c'est ça
très intéressant
c'est étonnant quand même j'arriverai je
revenais pas je l'aurais jamais saisies
dans ce match
décider ce qu'elle veut pas que tout
revienne pas mal bien jouer un
coup c'est un coup pas mal
en fait sont encore plus magnifique que
magnus réussit pas la gagner voilà c'est
le cauchois
enrichi
allez on va espérer une défense donné
pour ce cas serait vraiment peut-être ok
là serait vraiment la pire partie de
l'histoire des championnats du monde
allez on va espérer la partie de merde
au bail mais bon c'est intéressant
mais pas gagné ça c est
très ordinaire quand même après colloque
frontale doit regagner défaite défaite
des fêtes et des partages non mais bien
quand les pires des partages de
l'histoire que écoute chez eux ce serait
magnifique mais bon j'y crois pas trop
[Musique]
enfin en tout cas ça rend heureux
aïe
ouais bah du coup avoir préparé on aura
le temps du coup de faire nos toutes nos
vidéos et où on a combien ferney de
5,2 une deux une grosse journée à 5 et
vous
non on peut se faire un petit
verra je dis des trucs très facile qu'on
peut
bien toujours on sera tranquille pour
les vacances de noël
mais tu sais kevin les parties donc
c'est vraiment ce qui permet de voir les
plus beaux coups et les plus creuses
échec ouais c'est frais
c'est fou de s'infliger des partis aussi
long pour voir ça en fait
en fait je pense qu'en blitz tu fais
tourner si ce qui est beaucoup plus
simple et je ne vois pas pourquoi il n'a
pas fait un pion pour je dirais tours 10
j'arrive pas à comprendre ce qui va pas
en fait a priori rien hormis confirmons
que ce qu'on peut dire c'est à quoi tu
as peur de damas je sais pas de quoi tu
as peur
s'inquiète que
ça je pas troller une fourchette rodez 3
pts d'être
gagné t'es pas bien sûr
je gagne mais ouais bah
oui non mais tu le sens au feeling façon
ça mais
on ce qui fait ça mais en fait tu voyais
novembre bizarre c'est que je recueille
h4 c'est pas si simple sur f3 avec la f3
rêve de damages de
français ça détour des vite
magnifique à voir une bande de cons
comme ça que
ce serait extraordinaire
je pense aller
manifester en fait il voulait jouer ça
je pense
à c'est ce qui explique sa semi nicolas
sur l'échiquier quoi ce serait une
partie niveau 17 cents
après bon le truc c'est que j pop j'ai
déjà sa marque est acheté à 13 preuve
que tu fais c'est prendre est taquin
week end tranquille c'est quand même mal
peut-être tu peux mais bon déjà de par
la tour que tu as toi 6e c'est un peu un
peu dégoûté quoi
parti
je suis j'espère qu'il va faire qui
craque et qui racks à ce que rater ça
c'est
entre la caf et le ratage c'est vraiment
ouais c'est niveau de 1700 1800 la
partie on va voir mais là il
reconcentrer à une demi heure il va pas
double raté en fait
il est toujours gagner en fait c'est que
l'art je sais que l'ordi donne à des
dévaluations stratosphérique si je vais
voir cesser je veux dire si raconte
c'est facile à gagner mais bon je sais
pas le fait qu'ils choke
projet je sais - 8 53 quand même et puis
et puis même si le quatrième coup de la
position de change -3 70 mais bon sait
jamais une gaffe
une caf
jamais à l'abri d'une gaffe pabx
masseguin dommage que l'image de
cigogneaux soutient une si tôt je suis
d'accord
ça joue tellement bien
élément femmes
la gaffe la glace la gaffe lagaf la caf
la gaffe
et on apprend d'une pub en plus mais je
sais je sais je sais c'est bien ça n'est
pas lui qui nous permet de voir une pub
ou deux s'il a tendance à s'accrocher
une bonne demi-heure ensuite c'est pas
mal
et où tu as du négativisme et à bruz
accès là on est très heureux du niveau
de jeu là au contraire dans votre bonne
humeur on espère que ça continue
140 que tu as montré c'est dommage
j'aurais public tempo n'est pour manier
explique aussi et tout d'un coup
mais pas que inclus à ces mariages ou
autres il va jouer la main qui menacent
de jouer
n'est pas très sûr
avec les blancs du mal à battre
parce que on est nombreux ordinateurs
des six avant c'était vraiment finir
normalement alors dix mecs autour des
ciseaux et en desserrant tu vas leur
dire
mais bon il a déjà commencé a gaffé
mamys aussi un petit peu
je me demanderais enfin j'ai vraiment
l'impression que tu viens fabiano niveau
de 10 et 2018
bailly serait peut-être aussi je sais
pas mais
après c'est toujours mieux quand à une
faible opposition d'otomaï
2018 a régressé un peu comme on met ça
sur en fait ça se vend au classement elo
la vente avait dit n'y a plus de deux
minutes est famille nos plus de 2008 tu
avais pas mal de joueurs que tu es
proche 27 90 soit 2 passes et la bonde à
perdre des points alors c'est jusqu'à
bonfillon qu'on a pris mais
du coup caruana a quand même perdu
quasiment 50 points elo
je sais pas combien d'entre eux 90 par
là il ya eu 28 30 32
donc c'est avec 40 points ta digne qui
plus à 2008
ban et pau qui fait sens tout le monde
en fait
donc oui coville a fait du mal à
beaucoup de joueurs
qui a des gens moins pratiqué et peut
être partie longue donc t'as pas eu cet
effort de concentration toi et puis
peut-être même au niveau travail que ce
soit pas été
igal en tout cas chez tout le monde
parce que quand t'as pas de tournoi n'a
pas d'échéance bah
moi je sais si pour ça ne joue plus et
que j'ai pas fait les efforts parce que
bon je dis ça joue plus ça joue plus je
fais autre chose et donc donc voilà et
donc je vais une cadeau de joueurs dans
une autre proportion dans le même cas
quoi
et ça explique aussi peut-être pourquoi
rapporte d'un coup il remonte au
classement rapporte jamais été connu
comme étant un gros travailleur et sivu
celui fait la même chose qu'il a
toujours fait et que les autres font
mois en restant stables il te passe
devant parce que c'est un joueur
talentueux
bon bien sûr il fait pas rien il charge
des petits deals de rendre machin mais
c'est pas
donc donc je pense aussi que fabregas et
à cause de ce creux vide
ou grâce aux qu'ovide grâce 30 c'est pas
l'allemagne soit issue a gagné ça alors
que c'était enfin j'aime son comble id
ce numéro là encore en 3 + 1 il te gagne
ça avec tour des sites sur les
firmaments bull est le fouet et là tu as
l'impression qu'ils se met en pls en
silence a fait ces partis dont je
n'arrive plus à comprendre les jours tu
as l'impression qu'ils se mettent en
place tout seul on me voir débarquer
langues sais tu réfléchis trop vois-tu
une pression un stress
[Musique]
c'est quand même impressionnant qu'en
partant de cette position là où sans
réfléchir on l'a proposé pions prendre
un premier tour des six
arbitres de truc c'est que même tu
réfléchis à tour des six d'abord c'est
ça la méthode de mécanismes encore 3 et
que du coup c'est chiant a tant réussi
six as dame prend le trou et donc ok on
va éliminer ce truc pour apprendre à vos
6 mai puis on y va et puis voilà c'est
fini c'est pas une longue réflexion en
fait pour trouver
bah écoute fabre page de pub à aller ça
va ça va décanter d'une salle à décanter
avec magnus infuser pour mieux décanter
[Musique]
ah ben ça joue
si ça finit un pendant la pub c'est un
peu con quand même
déjà vu qu'ayyash 4
auquel h4 qui doit faire f prend
absolument obligatoire pour éviter la
double menace de match était d'amener de
et cabaye f3
oui mais bon ça ok c'est gagnant mais on
ne sait jamais et vacances est terrible
il ya peut-être devoir jouer une finale
avec nivea la gagner mais en très très
long non mais ce serait beau pirate cinq
ans mais
je serai vraiment est la pire partie de
l'histoire
chic
10 mai blender assez incroyable niveau
de jeu quand même fable iii après
blender bon ça devrait uniquement mais
c'est pas propre en tout cas on est
d'accord classe et là il est plus très
en dessous de 2000 c'est pas beau c'est
pas beau c'est quoi ces 1500 1600
morts en fait ouais il a voulu assurer
que son cadet f5 il a juste oublié la
vente des procès sept et
[Musique]
ouais séquence à 1600 1700 lots
romaine caps
très haut mais le 400 m était toujours
très haut parce que comme ils ont
beaucoup de couvertures 91 contre 96 en
fait tu en as toujours tu peux faire de
la merde en a toujours un cap avec
ouverture au dessus de 90 je joue
vraiment très bien ça va tellement rien
dire ce truc de casse bon bah du condroz
la pub j'ai envoyé en fait tu as a
encore pu évoquer mon fait la pause
la source n'a pas filtré
on est de retour cette partie qui
devient assez extraordinaire on se
croirait en sabbath almont fab
la lettre de bons coups
gagnants
bref un cas f3 c'est quand même pas mal
sa menace
peut-être dû d'am-dam géant
dames g2 et or prend des 6 et diani la
dame
donc les blancs d'offres une parade
qu'ils n'ont pas à la cebo les posters
m'intéresse c'est beau est-ce qu'ils le
feraient exprès
elle prend ses sept quoi
ce qu'il a fait prof c'est plus humain
autour des 6 tours angers 6 et ça il a
loupé des princes et 7 à la fin
exactement
ce que j'imagine il a pas imaginer
qu'ils viennent défenseur qui a quatre
en fait il y en a pas mais du coup c'est
plus beau but aléatoire des six était
très convaincant quand même aussi pas
plus convaincant
ça va quand même gagner a priori
terrible
on est quand même fait une défense de
fer un dommage pour lui
ça a défendu de l'acier mais non
il a joué d'ailleurs un truc comme ça j
m il a fait
rater change finalement
j'avais longtemps et la guinée
peut-être 2 3 depuis c'est pas mal mais
encore la pub à st
quand même tout l'intérêt combien de
pages de publicité fin du match
maj 3 jouer
j'aime pas quels points
103 contre
l'autre jour et tu perds
tous partagent pas ses actions passées
avec les blancs
d'être rapide finale
tu f5 montant droit machin c'est vrai
c'est être partout trop de faiblesses
trop d'activités
il ya tout bien pour les orioles qui ont
de plus si l'activité
mais ça peut durer un peu vrai
avait du coup un mâle nature et qu'il a
fait exprès quoi tu fais exprès de ta
fille j'ai vu que tu vas perdre en 4h
quoi
il a rien vu en fait tu veux faire
exprès battu fait juste pas d'âme f2 13
points 3 d'objets de maths et puis là ça
il a rien fait exprès du tout
magnus a pu faire exprès non mais lui il
veut être champion du monde qu'est-ce
qui peut finir qui fait m'attendais à
faire ma tendre il va faire du
reggae
man you ça il n'a raté que des
processeurs défend
et c'est pas grave de rater ça
voilà un jeu a évolué mais vu la
pression est tellement bonne et que
c'est pas grave et n'est par contre
pas
ces montants je n'ai jamais sont
instruits peu il peut se mettre ou pas
enfoncé pas mais
autant je vais peut-être ou quoi mais
quand je revois encore aujourd'hui je me
dis ah quand même à un moment qui est
vraiment plus quoi
ça qu'à me prendre du temps à se
reconstruire
qui était en deuil on faisait jusque-là
parties à zéro intérêt c'était pour
donner un peu d'intérêt qu'ils gaffe que
c'est un truc marrant sinon on va être à
l'impression d'avoir passé une nouvelle
journée s'ils me parce qu'on regarde en
fait
mais surtout chasse comme tu regardes un
blitz à peu près la même chose quoi non
tu prends une partie random du scroll un
petit
appareil
dans la petite finale
c'est terrifiant
et c'est dire beaucoup
d'efforts pitch est vers la fin d'un
suspense pas toujours
la stricte digérer banques eba sera pu
être déjà fini du coup magnus a plutôt
transporte dans une finale où les
gagnants et donc ça devrait signer
aujourd'hui mais ça va encore durer quoi
ça pourrait déjà être fini un ca
pourrais je pense surtout des six
fait tourner si je veux dire
la réponse c'est la partie en fait il a
sacrifié la qualité de l'eau vers le roi
est lui beaucoup d' attaque alors même
en faisant pas les coûts optimaux salut
dans une finale avec un pion de plus ce
qui est gagnant si tu vois il avait
alors qu'il rentrait en d2 serre très
fort je reviens de tours soit seconde
rangée
un tas de pions pas ch donc tu as plein
de choses avions passent et à une tour
active talent qui va être bien bientôt
taton pion qui avance
le mucho
faire qu elle attendait de moi je suis
retourné leur
faudrait pas trop de questions quoi
bon pas vrai dire il a raison fléchir la
main d'une minute et 2 34e coup
par raison de blitz et les coûts pour se
planter mais là bon je prends tu peux
pas te planter un tutu fâche c'est sûr
c'est bien de ferrare fuites sur ses
bienfaits à tous les coups normaux sont
bien
tour d2 c'est le plus normal de tous
on met les blancs n'ont pas gagné les
blancs sont perdants ces marques doivent
gagner en tant que joueur je sais pas je
vois je pense j'ai de bonnes chances de
gagner
je suis en mesure de me tromper aussi
parce que parce que je peux te nul mais
je serai vraiment pas content s'ils
gagnent pas 1 mais [ __ ] je suis
vraiment content quoi
c'est encore cette tradition fut
champion monde écrivent un livre sur les
parties du championnat non on sait qu'à
l'époque tu revenais dessus analyse a
vraiment carlson il est jamais revenue
sur okende aucune de ces victoires
et ça fait déjà un moment on fait
peut-être si un jour les retraités
pourra faire
un truc sans sa carrière qui c'est mais
non ça va
mais finalement il est bien où
elle correspond bien au scénario du
match a complètement inintéressant et de
piètre qualité
que c'est vraiment la partie qui reflète
le match ça résume en une partie ça a
concentré une licence de ce match en une
partie
je suis à tour des deux
opus magnus le truc c'est qu'en plus il
est vraiment bien pour gagner des
finales où il est mieux il les joue
vraiment correctement
mais en fait armand 6 questionne en fait
c'est
qu'il ya quand même d'autres trucs à se
demander
bref singh clos c'est bien vrai c'est
bien organique se met donc au tour des
deux hommes il faut vraiment faire
tomber un pour les blancs parce que si
tu pousses le pion va du coup le tour va
se glisser derrière
tremblay un pas terrible après s'il veut
faire bk te fait un bep prend à monter
ok il a fait tourner en tout cas le coup
logique donc on s'attend à tours tours b
sont mais après bastia tu peux commencer
cinq j'aime beaucoup j'ai si ça peut
être bien enfin watch 5 g 6 pendant que
l'un des proches 17 et tout ça donc
étant bien fait après tout peut-être
même faire tour ces deux pour tuer tout
contrôlé à base de baies 4
on ne sait pas grand chose sur b4 pour
ses trois bébés à tourbes et 5
pour ces deux débiles
[Musique]
sidibé cas de prise
parce qu'on prend un tueur fait tour à
deux
on attend ces dossiers éco / conso
sein qui vendait roche repart du coup
les plus loin de hb je sais pas bright a
sûrement mille bien
cuite vêtements fin
complètement gagnant
ce choix
jon magnus s'il préfère monter son roi
dit fait un effet sinko h5 je sais pas
plein plein de choses après vu comment
il a gaffé il peut un peu suédois
au mais il a gaffé par une erreur de
calcul un truc demande pas si une
défense
là c'est plus trop du calcul en fait
c'est toujours du calcul et finalement
je veux dire
au québec est c'est parti mon attente un
peu son contre jeu il s'enlève une
faiblesse en b2 pourquoi pas bon j'ai
bien nous apprendre que t'as pas envie
de laisser les blancs prendre et quand
tu reprends ça ouvre la colonne des
années en bessin un coup d'essai un jour
tous taxés des pions donc il prend voilà
sur puis on prend les atours ado dont je
vais lui apprendre de la tour
et peut-être quand même tour à deux
comme ça sur tours ces quatre tu fais
ces cinq études bloc 7 tours
poitiers retour à de tout de suite tu
peux te faire d'autres coups aussi
complètement gagnant et montfort faut
terminer au général
non jamais sein d'une partie gagnante on
sait
mais là c'est peut-être trop gagnant
un peu de bol après avoir raté le tour
des six ça aurait pu ne pas fonctionner
il est un peu la réussite dans ce match
mais était trop bien pour
pour c'est une conséquence comme le jour
sont dame b4y l'a pas vu la main ou un
truc comme ça
donc toi de jouer très bien ça ça rend
la tour blanche un peu passive obligés
de rester à la défense de ce pion sur la
quatrième manche et en plus tu peux te
la faire coincer situés autour c4 c5
10h35 après bouge plus
donc
[Musique]
et blanc plus cherchent des trucs datant
des capteurs mme lagarde je vois pas
didier juste là bas rien faire les noirs
il va te faire peu importe tour à 3
d'être prochain pour amener à penser
qu'à tourner vers le c5 et compagnie
talent pur h qui vend ses comptes et ont
ravagé cette relève si ce machin est
juste trop trop trop bien
et voilà
parti n'a pas l'intérieur
y a pas forcé son talent non non ça
c'est dans le chatt 0 magnus a pas eu
besoin de très bien jouer il a juste
fait le taf il a joué un niveau bien
mais pas pas très bien peu sûr qu'il
peut faire plus mais bon j'aime quand ça
suffit de faire ça tu vas pas non plus
c'est bon quoi
prenons un vieux
800 gaffeur de blender mais là bon c'est
caricatural puisqu'on lui donne page
pour jouer n'importe comment c'est que
je les donne pour tout le travail de sa
vie hier que la folie gagné candidats
avant être en mesure de qualifier aux
candidats être en mesure d'être top 5
mondial d'avoir fait des heures
d'entraînement petit à petit en fait on
te paye pour tout ça en poche juste pour
fait ça ici non plus
ça
pour elle avant même pas
encore un espoir je sais pas lequel et
puis sur ce truc dean je sais pas
l'expliquer ce qu'il fait mais un
qu'abandonner c'est un coup mais bon
saadé +5 ou une fois que tu as fait g3
qui t'a pris le truc
que maintenant
re 4 où il va tenter de contrôler avec
le roi devenir des 5 à 6 sauf que
produit qui a pu repasser de l'autre
côté
on va jusqu'à 4h de notre
régie s'ils allaient reprendre
exactement
peut-être revenir pour les
jeux counter
dash clinton
enfin il nous fait re 1,5 je pense pour
venir voter gaffes comme que tu as sur
l'espion stupar j'avance
sourit aussi vite alors pas déjà tu es
ce que magnus il a besoin d'être bien
sûr c'est leur rapporte rien ne vais
plus vite ou moins vite qu'ils gagnent
en une minute ou en huit heures il
marque qu'un point et il sera patrick
enfin il sera pas sympa plus champion du
monde pour autant
on voit la pub à nous aussi mais bon le
voient passer du coup c'est sûr ça
marche en fait mais
bon si jamais on se trompe on montre en
avant ta merde on se trompe on revient
bien lui la palois une fois qu'il a vu
que c'est tromper basse et je veux c'est
jouer donc il a bien raison de vérifier
car il l'a vu même encore plus vite que
nos jeux des rentes
et les pauses avant quelqu'un qui a
besoin de pain
hélas après dans ce match il a déjà fait
le coup aura des saints qui y va à fond
bon bras h4 on va voir la ligne clé
douche pour une touche c'est beau de
finir le match sur un 12 plutôt chaude
noir c'est calme ou s'il veut faire ton
segade qu'il le fasse ça changera pas la
face
la position puisqu'ils étaient remplacés
5,7 en vie puis si le roi par l'abattoir
on s'est même chose depuis ont acheté
avant c'est à son comparse g qui va
avancer aussi
et donc donc voilà
ces parties qui dure un peu pour pas
grand chose bassil 16h30 pub peut-être
ah oui et puis d'autres 1h19
ça devrait finir avant 17 heures quand
même je pense mais je pense qu'au final
je pense dans les dix minutes ça finit
le match 4 à tanger larache 4
6 à 3 6 6 3 et 5 h de forage 4 g sync au
pij et quattro et g13 et g2 et g10 ou
non vers la dame à
sa palette
est complexe
comme ça j'espère que mes mensonges
battle vous feriez les douches pinto
choix
là mais mon sabata je vais gagner
une partie qui reflète complètement le
match en entier ouais ouais ça résumé ça
un condensé images le nectar de ce match
en cinq parties
jamais intéressant toujours ennuyeux
baron fou salahi la gagne en vrai assez
facilement je pense
geagea et élie à 15 heures qu'il fallait
très une et deux heures ça se décante
bien quoi c'est bien décantée
on
s'ennuie pas une minute on se fait chier
j'ai pas vu la gaffe on arrive à perdre
avec le long l'ac arles est les dérives
se tient à la fin j'ai 3 23e coup
terrifiant comme ça
là on n'y peut plus grand chose pour
ryan
l'a complètement il a complètement
craqué
joueur russe
l'a vraiment fait g3 j'ai dû le quitter
à bah oui mais bon on a appelé le g3 il
est arrivé un
élan au fameux g troll sa part et c'est
hallucinant quand j'y croyais pas gênant
il s'assied réfléchis peut pas le faire
bah oui oui mais si en fait il peut
chaque di la fé son côté edf dans le
match quand même quoi et non non non
c'est incroyable quand même
ça calcule
mais j'aime bien quand même c'est pas
bien sûr il veut vraiment être sûr
qu'ils calculent
donc ça c'est en fait t'as vraiment
affiche 5 un peu engagés dans le truc
oui moi je pense mais
avec quoi je vais d'autres en fait je
sais pas j'ai pas trop j'ai parents
d'autres candidats dans la position
de tête tu fait forcément si je prends
c'est toi le sang et or 6 4 alors est ce
que ça change grand chose je propose
qu'on fasse une dernière petite pause
avant la fin du tournoi
mesdames et messieurs
ya joué tour ces deux
qui gagne aussi fait tous gagnent enfin
c'est difficile de dire fois ce soir
l'ordinateur donne plus de tweets
mission évidente à gagner pour l a gagné
avec 20 secondes sur la pendule
ça peut durer encore longtemps mais
c'est juste compliqué a commenté parce
que c'est une partie qui dure trois
heures qui est de la qualité d'un 3 + 0
donc
d'un moment ça devient ça devient
difficile après voilà où je suis content
c'est une excellente pub pour pour les
parties rapides et pour pour les blitz
et pour les rapides fab ce championnat
du monde finalement il aura au moins le
mérite or troll 1 il aurait eu une
maîtrise mérite de remplir ce rôle est
d'être la meilleure pub qui puisse
exister pour
pour le raccourcissement des cadences et
c'est déjà du bien en fait
après son torse de à vrai dire
objections j'aime bien
dire tu veux faire ton race et si tu vas
faire tourner ses 4 h 4 tu fêtera ses 6
6 h 3à je dois faire f5 et tu vas te
faire un tour prend ses trois échecs sur
la route voilà
c'est chercher la petite
nuance
irait pas pour le goût des autres coûté
très bien aussi mais
il veut essayer de jouer les bons coups
est ce que je préfère le commentaire de
ce pitch et sierre tout ça là pour le
coup oui
voilà une nouvelle partie à chaque fois
quand même enfin ça c'est quand même au
dessus de ça c'est pour dire à quel
point on est on est tombé bas que le
speech est mais je pense en fait que
l'événement société générale hier était
en fait au dessus des 2 autres n'ont pas
j'ai pas pu le voir non mais le speech s
autant le format est trop long et sa
patte à de faire jouer autant de parties
fin sur pareil il faudrait faire le
format 17 ou quoi mais pour le goût tu
vois une partie entre fort joueur
nouvelles toutes les toutes les 10
minutes en moyenne je sais pas disons ou
après un peu moins mais bon donc si tu
prends parti par parti sens fouquet sur
l'intérêt du match phare dé bonne partie
dans le temps à coire ici à man pour yb
on était dans une bonne note
hélas
là en fait
c'est parce qu'il se passe quoi voilà
c'est le néant
mais bon belle pub pour les partis
pour les parties rapides et beats au
final vous voulez sortir du positif de
sa pas bhl c'est finalement ce que ce
qu'il ya de positif à ce match
un petit avantage qui a 3 6
h trois races et 7h de la tourbe et un
ipod touch à b6
et sinko commerc omer asik au quattro
asaïs 13
pour la gauche
rob et 7j dos dames un sacrifice pension
dos santos qui et c'est peut être un
exemple voilà c'est en train de c'est en
train d'arriver
moi donc c'est un exemple tout ce qui va
se passer la force des doges puntos
victimes faciles aide
abandonnée
au les partis pour un parti jusqu'au
bout un
joujou jusqu'au bout
prayssas pourquoi pas mais c'est bizarre
en fait de se concentrer à fond quant à
-10 et de se lever tout le temps quand
on fait se lève tout le temps quand
c'est chaud quand c'est intéressant et
quand la position encore équilibré et
dès qu'il a moins 10 sur l'ordi à tient
même j'ai vraiment me concentrer pour
revenir dans la game the lancet allant
vers un contre sens
je crois c'est parti 37 c'est sûr
hop la
h-2a c'est sûr aussi je dirais
[Musique]
il se lève et
services est vraiment infernal en fait
non mais juste tu peux enfin c'est pas
faire un spectacle comme ça c'est juste
pas possible en fait en plus mais je
n'ai rien contre mais glisse mais enfin
juste comment comment t'as jamais de
réforme de saint c'est ça en fout en
fait ça rend fou
mais c'est franchement tu mets un écran
noir c'est pas moins intéressant quoi
c'est quand même super chiant
mais il se lève pas pour aller chier sur
moi non mais vraiment en plus
la faille face genre c'est pas un match
à chier quoi mais
c'est l'extraordinaire quoi ce truc est
complètement gagnant sera plus aucun
intérêt depuis une heure et demie et et
il a envie et mais pourquoi pas et les
veaux vaches y est aussi
non mais c'est
assez ça c'est là c'est la dernière
partie du match c'est fou
quel dommage qu'il n'y ait pas de partie
d'au moins pas avant ou la
non et vous voulez en voir d'autres et
que vous pouvez dire ça les américains
en fait
t'as pas envie terre la mairie de nogent
moment donné
cheveux
mais t'as pas envie d'abandonner des 32
l'on a
c'est terrible
ce qui revient
il a fait un petit f6
bombay le dodge sprinter
elle vaut réussissant
trois hommes pas bon bah tu peux essayer
mais au tertre au rachat ça marche quand
même plus ou moins mais mais il va
éviter tout rejet
et arrive
sagot des frissons à l'hectare waouh ça
peut être pour les photos pour les
sponsors aussi je sais pas comme au tour
de france dont deux filles tu fais bien
ton maillot
de faire tout rachat pour bien perdre un
temps et on va le g5
demande du tour b2 bon vous pouvez mais
bon on bouge à leur tour après tour b 2
pourquoi pas pour défendre b 6
6 puis tomber deux fait retrouver de
faire ici j'ai 50 ans et 3
très bien
joué on dormait 3 c'est
sûr
pour prendre tour ndam il va pousser un
peu le pion à mais j'aurais préféré
l'autoroute 20 points sa plus simple que
çà çà çà pas reproduire ten dam de plus
calmes et
je sais pas je revends ont fait l'autre
tombé 3 c'est fait mais je dois faire
ton tour un chant nouvelle dame
est ce qu'il va le faire une main ou à
demain jamais encore un point de
règlement très important ah oui ah oui
là il faut regarder les femmes se
mettent en plein écran
il fait tout ennemi est-ce que ça a été
fait dans les règles de l'art il faut
mettre le pion aux chiens l'enlever moi
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas il a
tout fait une main
comme quoi y'a encore du suspense
pendant un petit moment dans cette
partie quoi
l'exécution de la promotion tout ça
à l'époque chercheur contre jeu qui
envoie le pion à
homps éric downs 4 est un peu pénible
quoi tu as dame six échecs et la tour si
elle bouge tel 3 qui sautent gaz
c'est pas bien
inscriptions monde ce soir minuit ce
soir des sommets le plus facile en fait
de loin de très loin
promenade de santé
si on va dont plusieurs physique ces
gens qui font rire donc la dame
a déjà tant à deux par jeu d'échecs est
normalement si on met en fait trois bons
certes quasiment jamais
imagine qui doit avoir comme des jeux de
pièces en plus je vois aussi d'avoir les
vides à melbourne
non ça c'est du batin
4,4 ça m'étonnerait vélo position juste
admettre plus l'infini qu il abandonne
pas ça c'est un truc qui me fascine
aussi c'est pourquoi il ya ni les lever
tu réellement tout le temps
et tout le temps de vous quand
quand les positions sont tendues il est
assis à s'accrocher comme un malade
continue
psycho est pas foutu sa maman moi ça me
dépasse ouais c'est pas du tout une
bonne gestion de temps et on voit ça
plus haut niveau amateur en fait ouais
ça c'est du niveau amateur ouais mais à
ce niveau là c'est
moi
même je les prends autant de parfois la
tour pour un 10 km dames non ça c'est
interdit retour une tour c'est une tour
après tu peux le faire des parties
amicales ou quoi mais
ça c'est plus d'usagers
là franchement ça me dépasse
tu comprends pas oui s'accroche tout ce
qu'il fait chrifa
ce
que je comprends pas enfin
je comprends
pas du tout moi je serais pour dire la
vérité n'est non je suis pas fan la
propagande je sais pas quoi
c'est la première c'est mal parti
[Rires]
on ne fera pas dire que j'ai pas envie
de dire attention
moi je sais que c'est cette poule
hommage à l'histoire
on n'a jamais vu des joueurs jour un tel
niveau avant
si on veut le dire sur le jeu au qu'on
va chier que ça c'est des plus belles
parties distant et matt champion du
monde asie essaye de me contredire c'est
moi qui compte la partie
aujourd'hui qui tournent des pièges
diaboliques n'ai pu faire droit à huit
dès 8h b8 et l'histoire change qui s'est
en fait tomber cet esprit qu'est ce qui
va voir que d'amener cette île c'est mon
jardin il va penser que c'est matt
bonjour livre de dépôt mais plus belle
partie aux championnats du monde le
livret
vous appelez de décoration comme on a vu
blancois
vachement pas le délire de
ces livres là on fait décoration vide
magnifique madjer autant qu'ils aient
trucs écrits quoi en fait fort
et je crois vous pouvez lire entre
maastricht à me paraît plus compliqué
claude feing pas plus compliqué à gagner
mais montretout gagne j'ai pas en partie
peut-être envie de rentrer là-dedans va
attaquer madame des huit saisons c'est
ce piège diabolique
bon t'es tu montes au ras du cou et
évite le piège diabolique mais regardez
un autre prêtre fait de tenter de faire
f 5 ça va toujours pas c'est beau
ça me paraît impossible non mais en fait
là pour le coup là je suis moins sûrs de
gagner ça qu'est ce que j'avais à
vancouver je sens je peux faire le con
le pion arrive que
c'est plus difficile je pense de gagner
ça
que de pousser les punto ch
non mais tu as perdre mais tout à gagner
on le sait parce que c'est très facile à
ce qu'on a fait mais de réfléchir
fracassi si adam des six en fait c'est
un problème
échec échec
tu fais rien en fait
baisse là je sens que c'est pas si
facile spéciaux
les pièges de con tu sais pas pourquoi
permis sa bombe à nu ce truc ce que
michael q2 il va trouver mais jamais
j'aurais convertis comme ça quoi si j'ai
le choix ils sont black epci g5 g4g 3g 2
un peu plus facilement
et il tient matin 26 alors 10
mt 6 je pensais bien que
jamais d'amis
3 6
et double attaque double attaque hausse
les jouer un coup n'est pas
un abandon avant ça y est c'est terminé
magnus carlsen est champion du monde
femmes c'est officiel
à la suite d'une partie finalement à
l'image du match ouais bah écoute
non bah ouais bah écoute aujourd'hui ce
n'était pas pas une partie de ouf bah
bravo magnus en tout cas pour son
sérieux dans le match
il a largement mérité surclassé son
adversaire et on va le retrouver une
fois encore dans un an et demi pour
défendre son titre
voilà on espère sera meilleur match que
cette fois comme on disait c'est pas de
son fait c'est vraiment l'adversité qui
a pas été à la hauteur cette fois
nous allons vous faire la petite vidéo
de riz cap et
mais en fait ils savaient déjà qu'ils
étaient lus s'officialise vois ça il
faut quand même sourire il est mais
voilà et donc oui
après quoi dire d'autre je sais pas
c'était pas un grand match
la broyé
est passé dans le hachoir seulement 11
parties très peu moins que le dernier
masters et du monde d'ailleurs
finalement plutôt mon nouveau parti moi
y en a en fait
et
voilà merci à tous d'avoir suivi et on
se retrouve tout à l'heure pour le
résumé et on vous dira